TO OUR ASSEMBLY PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT AND RETIREMENT
COMMITTEE AND SENATE LABOR
PUBLIC COMMITTEE AND RETIREMENT
COMMITTEE THE JOINT
INFORMATIONAL HEARING.
I'M HERE DRAWING WITH --
MY COLLEAGUE SENATOR CHERRY HILL.
ALSO WITH THAT --
I'M ON A WALKER MEMORY FOR BEING
HERE.
WE HAD A SOMEONE HEARING ON FOR
RE THIRTEENTH REGARDING PUBLIC
RETIREMENT AND THIS IS THE
SECOND.
OF TWO JOINT HEARING THAT WILL
PROVIDE AN EDUCATIONAL OVERVIEW
OF OUR SHARE JURISDICTION.
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT STATE CIVIL
SERVICE AND COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING IN CALIFORNIA HAVE A
LONG AND PROUD HISTORY OF
AGENCIES AN INDIVIDUAL SERVING
THE NEEDS OF CALIFORNIANS.
TODAY WERE GOING TO HEAR FROM MY
DIVERSE PAN OF INDIVIDUALS
INVOLVED IN THESE AREAS.
WE'RE GOING TO START OUT WITH AN
OVERVIEW FROM THE ALEJO'S OFFICE
STATE PERSONAL BOARD.
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT RELATIONS
BOARD REGARDING THEIR RESPECTIVE
ROLES IN THESE AREAS.
THEN WE'LL HEAR FROM A RANGE OF
INDIVIDUALS REPRESENTING PUBLIC
EMPLOYERS THE STATE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND PUBLIC EDUCATION.
AS TO THE ROLES.
AND FOR THE FINAL PANEL WILL
HEAR FROM THOSE WHO REPRESENT
THE WORKERS WHO ARE THE FRONT
LINES OF PUBLIC SERVICE.
AT THE END THERE'S A REPAIR FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT SINCE PUBLIC
COMMENT IS LIMITED INDIVIDUALS
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SUBMIT
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS CAN PROVIDE
THEM TO THE COMMITTEE.
NOW TURN OVER TO CENTER HERE
PROVIDE SOME OPENING REMARKS AS
WELL THANK YOU CARE RODRIGUEZ
AND THANK YOU
.
FOR THE COVERS BOTH THE ROLES OF
LABOR AND THE IN PUBLIC
EMPLOYERS IN CALIFORNIA WHICH IS
CRITICAL.
AND IN THIS DAY AND AGE --
IT IS MY YOU DEAL WITH THAT MORE.
TRYING IN CHALLENGING ISSUES
HEAD ON IN CALIFORNIA SO IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT YOU'RE HERE TODAY
I LOOK FORWARD TO THIS HEARING
AND CERTAINLY.
IF THERE IS AS CHAIR RODRIGUEZ
SAID ANY OTHER COMMENTS THAT YOU
MAY LIKE TO TO MAKERS SUBMIT
PLEASE.
LET US KNOW AND WE'LL BE HAPPY
TO TAKE THEM UNDER CONSIDERATION
AS IT MOVES ON TO THANK YOU
CHARITIES AND MOVE ON THANK YOU
WITHOUT WILL GO AHEAD AND START
OUR FIRST PANEL.
THE OVERVIEW OF CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC SECTOR EMPLOYMENT STATE
CIVIL SERVICE AND COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING.
WE HAVE NECK SHOULDER PRINCIPLE
FIRST FISCAL AND POLICY ANALYST.
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
SUZANNE AMBROSE EXECUTIVE
OFFICER THE STATE PERSONNEL
BOARD.
AND JOSH SHRUGGED GOAL CAUGHT
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT RELATIONS BOARD.
AND JUSTICE THEY WILL HAVE
TWENTY MINUTES --
CAN DEPENDING ON HOW YOU PRESENT
YOU COULD.
DIVVY UP THE TIME AS LONG AS WE
COME UP TO TWENTY MINUTES OR
LESS.
CONSIDER WHAT JEFF SO WITH THAT
GO AHEAD AND TEARS.
MY NAME'S NICK SCHROEDER AND THE
LEGISLATIVE.
ANALYST'S OFFICE OF THIS MORNING
FIRST RUN GONNA DO IS INTRODUCE
OUR OFFICES ROLE MORE BROADLY IN
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AND THEN
TALK SPECIFICALLY ABOUT.
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AND OUR
OFFICES ROLE IN THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING PROCESS.
SO OUR OFFICE PROVIDE HAS FOR
THE PAST SEVENTY FIVE YEARS OR
MORE THAN SEVENTY FIVE YEARS
PROVIDED NONPARTISAN FISCAL
POLICY ANALYSIS TO THE
LEGISLATURE.
AND IN THAT ROLE WE PROVIDE
ANALYSIS AND ADVICE TO MEMBERS
OF BOTH PARTIES OF BOTH HOUSES --
AND WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
REOCCURRING PRODUCTS THAT I WAS
GOING TO HIGHLIGHT JUST --
FOR WE DO OF FISCAL FORECASTS
WERE RE LOOK AT THE STATE'S
EXPENDITURES AND REVENUES AND WE
DO THAT EACH YEAR IN NOVEMBER
AND AGAIN IN MAY.
AND THEN AFTER THE GOVERNOR
INTRODUCES HIS BUDGET IN JANUARY
WE THEN DO A SERIES OF REPORTS
LOOKING AT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSALS AND ALSO ALTERNATIVES
FOR LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER
BETWEEN JANUARY.
AND WHEN THE LEGISLATURE
ULTIMATELY A TOPS --
ITS BUDGET PACKAGE AND IN THE
THIRD CATEGORY IS INDEPENDENT
REPORTS OR ALSO MEMBER REQUEST
IT'S KIND OF ONE CATEGORY WHERE
IT'S WE'RE LOOKING AT A SPECIFIC.
PROPOSAL OR POLICY AREA.
IN MEMBER REQUESTS ARE OFF THE
STREETS THESE AS CONFIDENTIAL
UNTIL WE'RE TOLD BY THE OFFICE
THE LEGISLATIVE OFFICE TO MAKE A
PUBLIC --
AND I BROUGHT AN EXAMPLE OF JUST
ONE OF OUR SELF GENERATED ONES
WERE BASICALLY WE HAVE AN ISSUE
THAT WE THINK THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD.
BE AWARE OF AND IN THE LAST
WORKLOAD --
PRODUCT THAT I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
IS OUR WORK FOR THE VOTER
INFORMATION GUIDE WHERE WE DO
THE ANALYSIS OF STATEWIDE BALLOT
MEASURES.
AND SO NOW TURNING --
TO THE COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
PROCESS.
UP PUBLIC EMPLOYEES IN
CALIFORNIA THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAIN PROCESS BIRD VARIOUS
DIFFERENT TYPES OF EMPLOYEES IS
ESTABLISHED THROUGH A NUMBER OF
STATUTES --
AND I THINK THE PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT RELATIONS BOARD OF
PRIVACY ABLE TO SPEAK MORE
DIRECTLY TO EACH OF THE STATUTES --
BECAUSE THE EACH PERTAIN TO
DIFFERENT TYPES OF EMPLOYEES.
BUT I WAS GONNA SPEAK
SPECIFICALLY TO THE RALPH C.
DEALS ACT BECAUSE IT APPLIES TO
STATE EMPLOYEES AND IT'S ALSO
THE ROLE THAT OUR OFFICE PLACE
IS IN THAT ACT.
AND SO UNDER THE ROUSEY DEALS
ACT --
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING IS BETWEEN
THE GOVERNOR REPRESENTS THE
EMPLOYER AND HE'S REPRESENTED BY
DEPARTMENT OF HUMAN RESOURCES AT
THE BARGAINING TABLE --
AND THEN THE EMPLOYEES ARE
ORGANIZED INTO TWENTY ONE
BARGAINING UNITS.
AND ARE REPRESENTED BY UNIONS AT
THE BARGAINING TABLE.
SO THE PRODUCT OF THESE
NEGOTIATIONS RANDOM OF
UNDERSTANDING --
AND YOU.
AND BEFORE THE MO YOU GOES INTO
PLACE ITS FIRST WE NEED TO BE
RATIFIED BY THE UNION MEMBERSHIP
AS WELL AS BY THE LEGISLATURE.
AND SO THAT REALLY GETS INTO
WHERE OUR OFFICE PLAYS A ROLE IS
THE LEGISLATURE'S CONSIDERATION
OF THAT AND WILL YOU.
AND SO SINCE TWO THOUSAND FIVE
OUR OFFICE HAS.
BEEN REQUIRED TO PREPARE FISCAL
ANALYSIS A PROPOSED DEMO USE AND
UNDER STATE LAW WE HAVE TEN
CALENDAR DAYS. TO TO CONDUCT
THIS REVIEW UP BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE THAN CAN CONSIDER --
WHETHER OR NOT TO RATIFY AN
AGREEMENT.
AND ESSENTIALLY THIS PROCESS
WORKS WERE THE DEPARTMENT HUMAN
RESOURCES ARE DEPARTMENT FINANCE
THEY WORK TOGETHER TO DEVELOP
THE COST ESTIMATES AND SUMMARY
OF THE AGREEMENTS.
ADMINISTRATION AND SUBMITS THEIR
SUMMARY THE AGREEMENTS AND THEIR
SUMMARY OF THE PHYSICAL FACTS
FOR OFFICE AND ONCE WE RECEIVE
THOSE DOCUMENTS THE TEN DAY
CALENDAR CLOCK BEGINS.
AND SINCE TEN DAYS IS IS NOT A
WHOLE LOT OF TIME TO REVIEW.
PERHAPS MANY AGREEMENTS THAT
ONCE THAT ARE SEVERAL HUNDRED
PAGES LONG WE REALLY DO --
KIND OF A KICKING OF THE TIRES
OF THE MINISTRATIONS OF
SUMMARIES AS WELL AS THEIR
PHYSICAL FACTS AND SO WE LOOK TO
SEE WHETHER THEY INCLUDED --
EVERYTHING THAT WE THINK THEY
SHOULD INCLUDE IN TERMS OF
SUMMARIZING THE PAN THE
AGREEMENT TO THE LEGISLATURE.
AND WHETHER THEY ACCURATELY
YOU'RE REASONABLY RICH AGREEMENT.
AND UNLIKE THE OTHER PRODUCTS
THAT I SHOWED EARLIER WHICH ARE
NOT PHYSICAL FORM.
BECAUSE OF THE TIME CONSTRAINTS
WE POSTED ON OUR WEBSITE.
PRINTED OUT AN EXAMPLE OF THAT
FOR YOU HERE.
AND AND THEN THE LAST PART OF
OUR RULES PROCESS IS THROUGH THE
BUDGET PROCESS SO EACH YEAR IN
JANUARY THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES PROPOSALS RELATED TO
AUGMENTING EMPLOYEE COMPENSATION.
AND WE MONITOR THOSE PROPOSALS
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE
CONSISTENT WITH.
OF THE MO USER BEEN RATIFIED BY
THE LEGISLATURE.
UP THAN THAT THAT CONCLUDES MY
FORMAL REMARKS.
THANK YOU WHO LIKE YOUR NEXT.
I'M UP.
SUZANNE AMBROSE I'M THE
EXECUTIVE OFFICER AT THE STATE
PERSONAL BOARD THANK YOU CHAIRS
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT
AS PP -- SO
S. P. B. WAS CREATED --
THROUGH THE STATE CONSTITUTION
ARTICLE SEVEN IN.
NINETEEN THIRTY FOUR AND IT WAS
IN RESPONSE --
TO YOU KNOW THE MAJORITY OF A
STATE JOBS WERE THE RESULT OF
POLITICAL PATRONAGE AND SO THE
VOTERS.
YOU KNOW BROUGHT AN INITIATIVE
TO SYSTEM.
AND PART OF ARTICLE SEVEN
CREATES A FIVE MEMBER.
BOARD APPOINTED BY THE GOVERNOR.
AND THEY EACH SERVE TEN YEAR
TERMS --
STAGGERED EVERY TWO YEARS BUT
THEY SERVE UNTIL THEIR REPLACED
AND SO SOMETIMES THE BOARD
MEMBERS WILL SERVE BEYOND THE
TEN YEARS --
AND TELL REPLACEMENT IS NAMED --
CURRENTLY OF ALL OF OUR BOARD
MEMBERS WERE APPOINTED BY
GOVERNOR BROWN.
AND ALL BUT ONE HAVE BEEN
CONFIRMED SO THEY HAVE TO BE
CONFIRMED BY THE SENATE --
AND BASICALLY ARE FUNCTIONS HAVE
CHANGED.
OVER THE YEARS SO OVER THE
DECADES THERE FAN NUMEROUS
ITERATIONS OF THE STATE
PERSONNEL BOARD ORIGINALLY STATE
PERSONAL BOARD WITH ALL THINGS
H. R. --
COMPENSATION YOU KNOW CIVIL
SERVICE THE ENTIRE GAMUT --
IN A NINETEEN ABOUT THE EARLY
EIGHTIES WHEN COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING CAME INTO.
YOU KNOW STATE EMPLOYMENT --
THE DEPARTMENT OF PERSONNEL
ADMINISTRATION WAS AND MANY OF
THE FUNCTIONS THAT S. P. B. DID --
STE PARTICULARLY RELATED TO
COMPENSATION AND BENEFITS.
TRANSFERRED OVER TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF PERSONNEL
ADMINISTRATION --
OUR MOST RECENT REORGANIZATION
OCCURRED IN.
TWENTY TWELVE AND WHAT WE DID
AND THAT REORGANIZATION WAS WE
TRANSFERRED ALL OF THE HR SORT
OF OPERATIONAL FUNCTIONS OF THE
STATE CIVIL SERVICE EXAMS THAT
TRAINING FUNCTION.
THE CIVIL RIGHTS OFFICE --
ALL OF THOSE OPERATIONAL
FUNCTIONS WENT OVER TO A NEWLY
CREATED DEPARTMENT.
DEPARTMENT OF HUMAN RESOURCES --
WE CALLED CALLI CHAR.
SO WHAT S. P. B. NOW FOCUSES ON
IS WE WE SET ALL THE POLICY
RELATED TO THE CIVIL ERVICE
SYSTEM -- WE
ISSUE ALL THE RULES AND WE
BASICALLY TELL THE DEPARTMENTS
HOW.
TO DO IT --
AND THEN WE AUDIT THEM TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE IN COMPLIANCE.
SO WE HAVE AN AUDIT FUNCTION --
WE WE HAVE A POLICY FUNCTION AND
THEN THAT'S ON THE SORT OF THE
SELECTION SIDE OF AS STATE
EMPLOYMENT.
AND THEN WE ALSO HAVE THE STILL
HAVE THE DISCIPLINE SIDE SO ANY
DISCIPLINARY ACTION IS TAKEN
AGAINST A CIVIL SERVANT --
HAS THE RIGHT TO APPEAL TO THE
STATE PERSONAL BOARD.
AND SO WE HAVE WHAT WE CALL
MERIT APPEALS THOSE SIR
CHALLENGES TO FOR INSTANCE EXAM
RESULTS OR IF SOMEONE'S BEEN
DISQUALIFIED BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T
PASS THE BACKGROUND CHECK --
THEY CAN APPEAL THAT TO US AND
THEN OF COURSE DISCIPLINE ONCE
YOU ARE A PERMANENT STATE
EMPLOYEE --
IF ANY OF YOU KNOW ANY
DISCIPLINE IS BEING TAKEN THEN
YOU HAVE TO BE SERVED WITH THAT.
IN WRITING AND YOU HAVE THE
RIGHT TO APPEAL THAT TO THE
BOARD.
SO WE GET WE HAVE ABOUT SIXTY
FIVE EMPLOYEES ON A THIRTEEN
MILLION DOLLAR BUDGET.
AND WE WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH
CALLIE CHART.
GREAT.
THANK YOUR MUCH OF NICOLA MIXED.
A GOOD MORNING --
MISTER RODRIGUEZ SENATOR HILL
AND STAFF JOSH WILL GO TO A AND
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT RELATIONS
BOARD.
ALSO KNOWN AS PER.
UP HERB IS A QUASI JUDICIAL
AGENCY --
CREATED BY THE LEGISLATURE TO
OVERSEE PUBLIC SECTOR COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING IN CALIFORNIA.
THE BOARD ADMINISTERS THE EIGHT
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING STATUTES.
OF THOSE ARE THE EDUCATIONAL
EMPLOYMENT RELATIONS ACT ERA.
THE HIGHER EDUCATION EMPLOYER
EMPLOYEE RELATIONS ACT HERE A
THE STATE EMPLOYER EMPLOYEE
RELATIONS ACTS COMMONLY REFERRED
TO AS THE BILL'S ACT.
THE MYERS MILIUS BROWN ACT.
THAT IS CITY COUNTY LOCAL
SPECIAL DISTRICTS SOME PEACE
OFFICERS IN THIS --
EXCLUDING SOME PEACE OFFICERS IN
THE CITY AND COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES --
WE ALSO ADMINISTER THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY TRANSIT
EMPLOYER EMPLOYEE RELATIONS ACT
WHICH DEALS JUST WITH THE
SUPERVISORY EMPLOYEES OF LA
COUNTY'S MTA.
THE TRIAL COURT EMPLOYMENT
PROTECTION GOVERNMENTS ACT WHICH
IS COMMONLY KNOWN AS THE TRIAL
COURT ACT.
THE TRIAL COURT INTERPRETER
EMPLOYMENT AND LABOR RELATIONS
ACT WHICH DEALS WITH COURT
INTERPRETERS.
IN THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL COUNCIL
EMPLOYER EMPLOYEE RELATIONS ACT --
DEALING WITH THE NON JUDICIAL
EMPLOYEES A IS JUDICIAL COUNCIL
A WE ALSO ADMINISTER THE PUBLIC
EMPLOYEE COMMUNICATIONS CHAPTER
WHICH IS A RECENT --
EFFORT DESIGNED TO PROVIDE
EFFECTIVE IN MEANINGFUL WAYS FOR
EXCLUSIVE REPRESENTATIVES TO
COMMUNICATE WITH THEIR
BARGAINING UNITS.
NOW PER HAS.
THE THE GOAL OF PERMITS TO
ENSURE CONSISTENT IMPLEMENTATION
APPLICATION OF THOSE. EIGHT
STATUTES IN WE JUDICATA LABOR
RELATIONS DISPUTES BETWEEN THE
PARTIES THAT ARE SUBJECT TO THEM.
AND THE DESIGN OF THE STATUE
JUST IS TO PROTECT THE EMPLOYEES
EMPLOYERS ANY EMPLOYER
ORGANIZATIONS FROM UNFAIR
PRACTICES WITH PER PROVIDING
SETTLEMENT RESOLUTION OF THOSE
DISPUTES.
THE BOARD ITSELF BY STATUTE IS
COMPRISED OF COMPOSED OF UP TO
FIVE MEMBERS APPOINTED BY THE
GOVERNOR AND SUBJECT TO SENATE
CONFIRMATION.
CURRENTLY WE HAVE A FOR MEMBERS
OF OUR BOARD THREE OF WHOM HAVE
BEEN CONFIRMED AND ONE WHO IS
AWAITING CONFIRMATION --
WE HAVE ONE VACANCY FOR A TERM
THAT ACTUALLY EXPIRES AT THE END
OF THIS.
CALENDAR YEAR IN CURRENTLY THERE
IS NO CHAIR --
FOR OUR BOARD THAT THE
SEPARATELY APPOINTED POSITION BY
THE GOVERNOR --
TO ONE OF THE FIVE EXISTING OF
MEMBERS --
IN ADDITION TO THE OVERALL
RESPONSIBILITY OF ADMINISTERING
THOSE STATUTORY SCHEME TO THE
BOARD ACCESS AN APPELLATE BODY.
TO DECIDE ISSUES TO CHALLENGES --
FROM --
DECISIONS OF THOSE BOARD THE
BOARD ITSELF MAY ALSO BE
APPEALED.
IN CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES TO THE
STATE APPELLATE AND SUPERIOR
COURTS --
JUST TO GIVE SOME HIGHLIGHTS OF
SOME OF OUR MAJOR FUNCTIONS.
OF THE MAJOR FUNCTIONS OF
HERBERT BOTHERED THE
INVESTIGATION AND ADJUDICATION
OF UNFAIR PRACTICE CHARGES ALL
GO INTO A LITTLE BIT OF DETAIL
WHAT THAT MEANS.
A IN A MOMENT OF THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE RABBIT
REPRESENTATION PROCESS SO --
THAT'S THE PROCESS BY WHICH
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES SELECT AN
EMPLOYEE ORGANIZATION TO READ
REPRESENT THEM IN THEIR LABOR
RELATIONS AT THE CUT USED TO DO
SO -- AS I
MENTIONED EDUCATION OF APPEALS
OF ORIGIN TERMINATIONS --
OUR OFFICE OF GENERAL COUNSEL
ALSO -- HAS
SOME LEGAL FUNCTIONS THAT THEY
PERFORM IN ADDITION TO THE ONES
THAT HAVE BEEN MENTIONED.
AND THEN AS OF TWENTY TWELVE THE
STATE MEDIATION AND CONCILIATION
SERVICE IS NOW A PART OF PER --
AND THEY PROVIDE MEDIATION
SERVICES TO MOSTLY PUBLIC AND
OCCASIONALLY SOME PRIVATE
CONSTITUENTS --
GOING BACK TO OF THE UNFAIR
PRACTICE CHARGES --
FROM.
IN EXAMPLES OF THESE --
INCLUDE THINGS ON THE EMPLOYER
SIDE -- SUCH
IS REFUSING TO NEGOTIATE IN GOOD
FAITH WITH AN EMPLOYER
ORGANIZATION DISCIPLINING ARE
THREATENING EMPLOYEES FOR
PARTICIPATING IN UNION
ACTIVITIES OR PROMISING BENEFITS
OF AN EMPLOYEE DOESN'T
PARTICIPATE.
IN UNION ACTIVITIES --
AND THEN THE EXAMPLES ON
UNLAWFUL ASIAN CONDUCT INCLUDE
THREATENING EMPLOYEES IF THEY
REFUSED TO JOIN THE UNION --
DISCIPLINING A MEMBER FOR FILING
AND FOR PRACTICE CHARGE AGAINST
THE UNION.
OR FAILING TO REPRESENT --
BARGAINING IN UNIT MEMBERS
FAIRLY -- AS
PART OF THE EMPLOYMENT
RELATIONSHIP WITH THEIR
EMPLOYERS --
QUICKLY I'LL JUST TOUCH ON SOME
OF THE LEGAL OTHER LEGAL
FUNCTIONS OF OUR GENERAL
COUNSEL'S OFFICE.
THIS COULD INCLUDE THINGS LIKE
DEFENDING FINAL BOARD DECISIONS
ARE ORDERS --
WHEN PARTY SEEK REVIEW IN STATE
APPELLATE COURTS --
SEEKING ENFORCEMENT WHEN A PARTY
REFUSES TO COMPLY WITH THE FINAL
BOARD DECISIONS OF EITHER OF THE
PARTIES DECIDES THEY'RE NOT
GONNA FOLLOW WITH THE BOARD
DECISION IS --
OUR OFFICE OF GENERAL COUNSEL
CAN SEEK INJUNCTIVE RELIEF
AGAINST THOSE --
PARTIES --
DEFENDING THE BOARDAGAINST
ATTEMPTS TO STATES ACTIVITIES OF
THE BORDERS IN THE DECISION
MAKING PROCESS --
AND SOMEONE TRIES TO ENJOY THOSE
ACTIVITIES OF THE OFFICE OF
GENERAL COUNSEL WOULD DEFEND
THEM.
AND IN GENERAL JUST DEFENDING
THE JURISDICTION OF THE BOWL.
IN CASES WHERE THE BOARD HAS A
SPECIAL INTERESTS SO IT MIGHT
NOT BE A PARTY BUT IS INTERESTED
IN THE OUTCOME.
OF IT -- I
MENTION THE STATE MEDIATION AND
CONCILIATION SERVICE AS A
SEPARATE ENTITY OF WITHIN PER --
THEIR ROLE IS A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT I JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THEIR MEDIATION AND
REPRESENTATION SERVICES.
SHOULDN'T BE CONFUSED WITH THE
ROLE OF HERB ON THE OFFICE OF
GENERAL COUNSEL OF THE STATE
MEDIATION CONCILIATION SERVICES
WORK IS PERFORMED ON THE BASIS
OF MUTUAL CONSENT SO THAT'S BOTH
PARTIES COMING TOGETHER DECIDING
THAT THEY WOULD LIKE TO TRY TO
MEDIATE AN ISSUE --
INSIDE EXCEPT IN CASES WHERE
IT'S REQUIRED BY A A CERTAIN
STATUTE.
AND THESE MEDIATIONS ARE NON DID
YOU TO COURT NON ADJUDICATORY
UNLIKE A PURPOSE OTHER --
ACTIVITIES WITH AND REALLY AN
EMPHASIS ON COMPROMISE ON IN
COLLABORATION TOWARD SETTLEMENT.
I WITH THAT I THINK I'LL LEAVE
IT THERE AND SEE IF YOU ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU JOSH I WITH THAT OPEN
UP TO ANY COLLEGE LIKE TO HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
WHEN QUESTIONS CENTER RECORDED
THANK YOU YOU ALL GOT WHAT TERM?
WOULD OF THE CASES THAT MAKE UP
A MAJORITY OF THE HEARINGS THAT
YOU HAVE IS TRYING TO GET A
SENSE OF MOST OF THE MOST OF THE
ISSUES THAT.
OPERAS OFFICE OF GENERAL COUNSEL
STARTS WITH THEIR THE ON FOR
PRACTICE CHARGES SO THOSE LIST
OF ACTIVITIES BY EMPLOYERS
EMPLOYER IN HIS ASIANS THAT ARE
UNLAWFUL --
AND COMPLAINTS THAT ARE FILED
WITH 70% OF OUR OFFICE THE
GENERAL COUNSEL'S WORKLOAD --
STARTS THERE --
BRING THAT DOWN A LITTLE FURTHER
MOST OF OUR WORK COMES FROM
EITHER THE EDUCATIONAL
EMPLOYMENT RELATIONS ACT OR THE
MYERS MILIUS BROWN ACT I WOULD
SAY.
THOSE TWO ACTS CREATE MOST OF
PROBES WORKLOAD [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER ANYONE ELSE
CENTER HIM.
THANK THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING
HERE AND I REALIZE THAT THE I
THINK THE MAIN FOCUS OF YOUR
TESTIMONY IS REGARD TO I THINK
THE COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
PROCESS AND ALSO --
THE THE FUNCTIONS OF YOUR
ORGANIZATIONS AND I KNOW CAL H.
R. ISN'T HERE --
BUT I I DID MINE JUST ASK A
BRIEF QUESTION TO KLAY OF THE
STATE PERSONNEL BOARD AGAIN A
REALIZE THIS PIPE MORE DEVOLVED
TO COLLEGE ARE --
A MILL MY OFFICE WERE CLOSE OF
COLLEGE ARE TO AND TO TRY TO
FIGURE OUT HOW WE INCREASE THE
DIVERSITY OF OUR STATE WORK
FORCE -- SO
AND IF YOU RUSSIAN SUE THE STATE
PERSONNEL BOARD.
AND YOUR RELATIONSHIP WITH
CALLIE CHAR AND AND AND AND HOW
AND AND SO.
IT AND SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
ARE YOU THINK THAT WE MIGHT BE
ABLE TO DO.
TO INCREASE.
THE DIVERSITY OF OUR STATE
WORKFORCE AND ALSO TO MAKE A
STATE JOBS MORE AVAILABLE TO A
BROADER SEGMENT OF FAR AS OUR
OUR COMMUNITY SHARE --
SO THE OFFICE OF CIVIL RIGHTS
USED TO BE WITH THE STATE
PERSONAL BOARD AND THEN IN
TWENTY TWELVE I GOT TRANSFERRED
OVER TO CALAIS CHAR SO --
YOU KNOW WE WORK VERY CLOSELY
TOGETHER ON THOSE ISSUES WE HAVE
A NUMBER OF SORT OF TASKFORCE
COMMITTEES THAT WE COLLABORATE
WITH FOR INSTANCE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION TO INCREASE
EMPLOYMENT OF PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES --
AND YOU KNOW IT IT'S REALLY
MULTI FACETED IT'S YOU KNOW
RECRUITMENT IT'S OUR REACH.
IT'S YOU KNOW.
IT'S MAKING THE SYSTEM USER
FRIENDLY --
SO THAT PEOPLE CAN NAVIGATE --
STATE JOBS WHO ARE ALREADY IN
THE PROCESS --
AND SO REALLY CALLIE CHART TAKES
THE LEAD ON BUT WE ALL DO WORK.
COLLABORATIVELY ALSO WITHTHE
YOU KNOW THE THE UNIONS ARE VERY
HELPFUL IN THAT REGARD AND AT WE
HAVE A NUMBER OF A AND NISHA
TIPS RESULTING FROM.
THE TASK FORCE WE PUT TOGETHER A
FEW YEARS AGO ON EMPLOYING
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES AND SO
WE'RE KIND OF WORKING THROUGH
THOSE TOGETHER.
NO THANK YOU --
AT THE THE THE YEAH WE NEED TO
BE SURE WE HAVE A STRONG CIVIL
SERVICE --
IN THE PROCESS THOUGH BEING
EMPLOYED BY THE STATE'S LITTLE
DIFFERENT THAN JUST GOING INTO
YES THEY CAN EXAMINE SOME OTHER
TYPES OF THINGS AS WELL.
SOMEWHAT SOMETIMES THAT
PROCESSES UNFAMILIAR TO PEOPLE
WHO ARE NOT FAMILIAR WITH STATES
SERVICE SO.
I I KNOW THAT ARE OFF MY OFFICE
WORK.
WITH CAL HR TO TRY TO DO SOME
EDUCATIONAL SESSIONS AND AND THE
DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE COMMUNITY
ACTUALLY INTERESTING ENOUGH WE
FOUND OUT THERE ARE PRIVATE
VENDORS DOING THAT AS WELL YES --
BUT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
STATE ITSELF PARTICULARLY SENT.
GOING OUT INTO YOUNG STATE TO
GIVE THEM THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
THEM TO APPLY FOR STATE JOBS.
BECAUSE IT'S NOT A CERTAIN LACK
OF ABILITY MAYBE LACK OF
UNDERSTAND KNOWLEDGE OF THE
STATE HIRING PROCESS WHICH IS
SOMEWHAT DIFFERENT FOR FOR LOTS
OF RAIN POURED REASONS.
THAT AND SIGNING UP FOR A JOB
WITH OF THE OF THE PRIVATE
EMPLOYER SHARE I MEAN THERE'S
YOU KNOW LANGUAGE BARRIERS
THERE'S IT'S AN ACCESS ISSUE.
AND THE MORE WE CAN REACH OUT.
TO YOU KNOW.
BASICALLY THE GENERAL PUBLIC.
BUT ALSO SPECIFIC COMMUNITIES IN
EL THE BONE THE BETTER THERE'S
THINGS LIKE TAKING EXAMS AND
BEING A WAITING LISTS AND THINGS
LIKE THAT THERE ARE GREAT
DIFFERENCES --
YES YES ABSOLUTELY YEAH I MEAN
THE BETTER OUR WORK FORCE IS
WITH DIVERSITY.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
I COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE'LL MOVE ON TO OUR SECOND
PANEL.
I WITH THAT WE HAVE --
THE PUBLIC EMPLOYERS ROLE.
FROM THE STATE WE HAVE ADRIA
JINKINS JONES IS THE ACTING
DIRECTOR CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF HUMAN RESOURCES.
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL WE HAVE DAY
IN HUTCHINGS LEGISLATIVE
REPRESENT OF THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES.
AND FROM SCHOOLS WE HAVE.
LAURA PRESTON LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS.
AND ONCE AGAIN JUST ONE IT RIGHT
YOU HAVE TWENTY MINUTES AND
WHOEVER LIKE TO GO FIRST GO
AHEAD THE FORGERS.
GOOD MORNING.
CHAIRMAN RODRIGUEZ AND HE'LL IN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I MAJOR
JACKETS JONES AND I'M THE ACTING
DIRECTOR OF DEPARTMENT OF HUMAN
RESOURCES.
THANK YOU FOR ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY TO BE BEFORE YOU
TODAY THIS TIME TO SPEAK TO YOU
ABOUT CAL HR AND AS THE STATE
EMPLOYER IN ITS ROLE IN LABOR
RELATIONS.
AND TO ADDRESS ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MAY HAVE IS THIS INTO HUMAN
RESOURCES AGENCY FOR STATE
GOVERNMENT AND OUR VISION IS TO
BE THE PREMIER LEADER ENTRUSTED
PARTNER.
IN INNOVATIVE HUMAN RESOURCES
MANAGEMENT WE DO THIS TO A
DELIVERY OF HUMAN RESOURCES
RELATED SERVICES.
SITTING POLICY IN PROVIDING
GUIDANCE TO STATE DEPARTMENTS
WITHIN THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH.
OF THE STATE WORK FORCE WITHIN
THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH AS A PROP
TO ME TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY TWO
THOUSAND EMPLOYEES.
OF THOSE TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY
TWO THOUSAND EMPLOYEES
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED AND
NINETY THOUSAND OF THOSE
EMPLOYEES WE FOR REFER TO AS
RAKE INFALLIBLE UNION EMPLOYEES.
THESE RANK OF ALLEN PLAYS ARE
SPLIT INTO TWENTY ONE BARGAINING
UNITS WHICH ARE REPRESENTED BY
TWELVE EMPLOYEE UNIONS.
IN ADDITION THERE ARE
APPROXIMATELY FORTY TWO THOUSAND
EMPLOYEES WHO ARE NOT
REPRESENTED BY UNIONS AND ARE
EXCLUDED FROM COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING THESE EXCLUDED
EMPLOYEES ARE GENERALLY MANAGERS
AND SUPERVISORS --
THEY DO NOT HAVE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING RIGHTS HOWEVER
EXCLUDED EMPLOYEES ORGANIZATIONS
HAVE THE RIGHT TO MEET AND
DISCUSS THE TERMS AND CONDITIONS
OF EMPLOYMENT WITH CALLIE CHAR.
IN TERMS OF OUR ROLE WITH STATE
GOVERNMENT CALLIE JARS
RESPONSIBLE FOR SETTING POLICY.
AND PROVIDING GUIDANCE TO STATE
DEPARTMENTS AND HUMAN RESOURCES
RELATED ISSUES SUCH AS STATEWIDE
RECRUITMENT.
JOB EXAMINATION DEVELOPMENT
ADMINISTRATION WORKFORCE
PLANNING WE ALSO MANAGE EQUAL
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITY PROGRAM
SUCH AS REASONABLE ACCOMMODATION
BILINGUAL SERVICES LEAP AND
CENSUS DATA.
WE ALSO OVERSEE THE
PSYCHOLOGICAL SCREENING PROGRAM
FOR PROSPECTIVE PEACE OFFICERS
FOR THE STATE.
I'M IN ADDITION CAL H. R.
PROVIDES GUIDANCE ON PERSONNEL
MATTERS LIKE LAY OFFS LEAVE
ADMINISTRATION EXEMPT
APPOINTMENTS.
AND IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
MAINTAINING THE STATE'S
CLASSIFICATION AND PAY PROGRAM.
WE MANAGE EMPLOYEE BENEFITS
PROGRAM SUCH AS VISION DENTAL
EMPLOYEE SSISTANCE PROGRAM FLEX
ELECTS LONG TERM DISABILITY AND
WORKSITE WELLNESS.
WE ALSO ADMINISTER THE SAVINGS
PLUS PROGRAM WHICH FOR BILL
PROVIDES EMPLOYEES A PATH TO
SAVE FOR THE FUTURE TO THE FOUR
ONE K. AND FOUR FIFTY SEVEN BE
PLANTS.
CAL HR ALSO PROVIDES LEGAL
SERVICES --
WE REPRESENT STATE DEPARTMENT OF
LABOR RELATIONS MATTERS CONTRACT
INTERPRETATION AND APPEALS OF
DISCIPLINARY ACTIONS.
ARE PRIMARY ROLE IS TO REPRESENT
THE GOVERNOR AS THE EMPLOYER IN
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AS A
RESULT OF THE PASSAGE OF THE
ROUSEY DEALS ACT OF NINETEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT UNDER THE DEALS
THAT CALLIE JARS REQUIRED TO
MEET AND CONFER.
IN GOOD FAITH WITH THE VERY
SIMPLE THIS HOURS IN TERMS AND
CONDITIONS OF EMPLOYMENT.
WHICH THERE ARE AGREEMENTS OVER
THOSE TERMS OF EMPLOYMENT THOSE
LABOR AGREEMENTS MUST BE
RATIFIED BOTH BY THE UNION
MEMBERSHIP AND THE LEGISLATURE.
AS OF TODAY WE CURRENTLY HAVE
CONTRACTS WITH TWENTY OF THE
TWENTY ONE BARGAINING UNITS.
THE CONTRACT FOR BARGAINING UNIT
FIVE FOR THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL OFFICERS REPRESENTED BY
C. H. H. P. EXPIRE JULY OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN SO WE ARE
CURRENTLY IN THE PROCESS.
OF NEGOTIATING WITH THEM.
THIS JULY WE HAVE CONTRACTS WITH
OF THE FIVE FOLLOWING BARGAINING
UNITS THAT ARE SET TO EXPIRE WE
PLAN TO BEGIN.
THE BARGAINING PROCESS WITH
THESE UNIONS IN THE NEXT FEW
MONTHS THOSE BARGAINING UNITS
ARE BARGAINING UNIT.
TO WHICH OUR ATTORNEYS
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE IT.
EMPLOYEES PRACTICING LAW FOR THE
STATE OR EXERCISE REQUIRES AYE
JUDICIAL JOB DUTIES WITHIN
ADMINISTRATIVE HEARINGS.
THEY ARE REPRESENTED BY CASE AND
HAVE APPROXIMATELY FORTY ONE
HUNDRED EMPLOYEES BARGAINING
UNIT SIX WHICH IS CORRECTIONAL
OFFICERS IN PEARL AGENTS WHICH
PROVIDE CUSTODY SUPERVISION AND
TREATMENT OF WARTS AND IT MADE
REMANDED TO STATE CUSTODY.
THEY ARE REPRESENTED BY CCPOA
WITH APPROXIMATELY TWENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED EMPLOYEES.
BARGAINING UNIT.
SEVEN PROTECTIVE SERVICES AND
PUBLIC SAFETY EMPLOYEES
RESPONSIBLE FOR PROTECTING STATE
LANDS AND BUILDINGS FURNISHING
EMERGENCY SERVICES AND ISSUING
LICENSES OR PERMITS THEY'RE
REPRESENTED BY C. S. L. T. PAY
WITH APPROXIMATELY SEVEN
THOUSAND EMPLOYEES.
BARGAINING UNIT THIRTEEN
STATIONARY ENGINEERS WHO
MAINTAIN AND OPERATE STATE
FACILITIES THEY ARE REPRESENTED
BY AYE YOU EAT WITH
APPROXIMATELY A THOUSAND
EMPLOYEES.
AND BARGAINING UNIT EIGHTEEN THE
PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS
PROVIDING PSYCHIATRIC CARE FOR
MENTALLY ILL IN DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABLED PATIENTS IN STATE
OPERATED FACILITIES.
THEY ARE PRESENT REPRESENTED BY
CA PETE THE SIXTY FIVE HUNDRED
EMPLOYEES.
IN ADDITION TO THOSE SIX THE
CONTRACTS WITH OUR LARGEST
EMPLOYEE UNIONISTS SEIU WILL
EXPIRE IN EARLY JANUARY.
TWENTY TWENTY SEIU REPRESENTS
APPROXIMATELY NINETY NINE
THOUSAND AND ONE HUNDRED
EMPLOYEES SPENDING ACROSS NINE
BARGAINING UNITS.
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO SHARE.
KELLY CHARTS BARGAINING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'M GONNA GO
NEXT.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS TING
HUTCHINGS WITH LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES SO I
APPRECIATE THE INVITATION TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE DAY AND
TELL YOU A LITTLE BIT ABOUT AT
THE LEAGUE STRUCTURE --
SITE INFORMATION ABOUT HOW THE
LEAGUE OPERATES AND HOW WE CAN
BE -- I
CONTINUE TO BE A RESOURCE TO TO
YOU -- AS
FAR AS IT WITH WITH RESPECT TO
THIS COMMITTEE --
BELIEVE CALIFORNIA CITIES BUT
ESTABLISH --
NINETEEN NINETY THREE CURRENTLY
REPRESENTS ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY FIVE AT THE FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO CITIES IN CALIFORNIA
OF WHICH EMPLOY HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF PUBLIC SECTOR
WORKERS --
INCLUDING MYSELF THERE SIX FULL
TIME LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATES
COVERING ALL ISSUE AREAS --
THAT IMPACT CALIFORNIA CITIES --
I AM THE GOVERNANCE TRANSPARENCY
IN LABOR RELATIONS LOBBYIST YES
THAT IS A COMPLETE MOUTHFUL --
GTL ARGUE IF THAT THAT'S WHAT WE
CALL AROUND THE OFFICE --
THE SCOPE WITH RESPECT TO MY AB
WORKERS COMPENSATION COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AND OTHER PERSONNEL
RELATED ISSUES --
IN ADDITION WE HAVE A REGIONAL
PUBLIC AFFAIRS AND GRASSROOTS
PROGRAM SO THERE ARE SIXTEEN
REGIONAL REPRESENTATIVE SPREAD
ACROSS CALIFORNIA DIVIDE INTO
THIRTEEN DIFFERENT REGIONS AND
SO -- A LOT
OF OUR LOCAL A LOT OF OUR
OFFICIALS AT AT THE STATE LEVEL
HAVE COME FROM THE LOCAL ELECTED
OFFICIALS SIDE.
ARE PROBABLY FAMILIAR WHO YOU'RE
WITH THREE REGIONAL
REPRESENTATIVE IS --
ADDITIONALLY WE HAVE
PROFESSIONAL DEPARTMENTS AND SO
WE'VE GOT --
WHOLE BOARD STRUCTURES FOR HR
DIRECTOR CITY MANAGERS FIND
INSTRUCTORS --
FIRE CHIEFS POLICE CHIEFS --
AND WHO ARE ALL EXPERTS AND CITY
GOVERNMENTS IN OPERATIONS --
WHO WE IS ADVOCATES RELY ON FOR
TECHNICAL EXPERTISE YOU KNOW HOW
HOW WITH THESE MEASURES IMPACT
THEIR DAY TO DAY OPERATIONS?
AND ITS OUR JOB TO CONVEY THAT
MESSAGE.
TO THE FOLKS SITTING AROUND THIS
ROOM --
ADDITIONALLY WE HAVE A WHOLE
SERIES OF DIVERSITY CAUCUSES SO
THEY'RE VERY MUCH SIMILAR TO THE
DIVERSITY CAUCUSES THAT YOU HAVE
HERE -- IN
IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LEGISLATURE SO --
DALY TINO CAUCUS AFRICAN
AMERICAN CAUCUS WHEN IT'S CAUCUS
AND OTHERS THAT ARE VERY SIMILAR
TO TO THE GOVERNANCE STRUCTURES
THAT YOU HAVE HERE IN THE STATE
LEGISLATURE --
IT IS OUR BOARD OF DIRECTORS
ALONG WITH THE LEADERS OF OUR
DIVERSITY CAUCUSES IN
PROFESSIONAL DEPARTMENTS THAT
COME TOGETHER ONCE A YEAR AND
ESTABLISH WHAT OUR STRATEGIC
PRIORITIES WILL BE FOR THE YEAR --
YOU KNOW --
TYPICALLY --
I'M I'M ON THAT LIST AS FAR AS
SOME OF THE STRATEGIC PRIORITY
SPECIFICALLY IN THE LAST COUPLE
OF YEARS --
PENSION --
PABON THOSE ISSUES HAVE BEEN A
STRATEGIC PRIORITY --
YOU KNOW WE TRY TO WORK WITH --
YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S MY APPROACH
MY PHILOSOPHER TRY TO ALWAYS TRY
TO WORK WITH COLLABORATIVE
COLLABORATIVELY WITH --
YOU KNOW OUR OUR BAR LABOR
PARTNERS WHETHER SAYS YEAH YOU
SEE P. HALF --
PORAC ANY OTHERS ON SOME OF
THESE ISSUES I THINK ONE ISSUE
IN PARTICULAR THAT WASN'T
LEGISLATIVE --
BUT WAS A VERY VERY GOOD FOR
EXAMPLE OF OF WAYS THAT WE
WORKED COLLABORATIVELY WISE --
MYSELF ALONG WITH --
CPF AND AND SOME OF THE LOCAL
FIRE UNIONS FOR THREE CITIES IN
ACTUALLY CENTER HILLS DISTRICT --
HELP TO WORK WITH CALPERS DID --
TO ESTABLISH THE SAN MATTEO
CONSOLIDATE FIRED --
THIS FIRE THIRTY ACTUALLY SAY
BEACH CITY ABOUT A MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY AND WE DIDN'T
HAVE TO LAY OFF ONE FIREFIGHTER
SO WE'RE ABLE TO DELIVER
SERVICES --
YOU KNOW FROM A REGIONAL
PERSPECTIVE --
WERE ABLE --
TO SAVE EACH CITY MONEY TO THE
MAKING THAT APPLY TO THEIR AT
THEIR UNFUNDED LIABILITY
PAYMENTS --
WHILE THE SAME TIME RETAINING OF
THE WORKER SO TRULY WAS A WIN
WIN AND IT WAS OPPORTUNITY FOR
LABOR MANAGEMENT TO COME
TOGETHER WORK WITH PURSE TO GET
TO GET THAT CONTRACT PUSH
THROUGH AND AND A PREFERRED
RETIREMENT SERVICES --
YEP GIVEN YOU KNOW AS FAR AS OUR
MAJOR FOCUS IS THIS YEAR IN THE
YEARS TO COME.
GIVEN THAT RISING PENSION AND
OPEC CONTRIBUTION RATES WILL IN
A IN OUR VIEW REALLY REDEFINED
THE WAY CITIES OPERATE --
PENSION SUSTAINABILITY SOMETHING
THAT WILL CONTINUE TO BE TO BE
FOCUSED ON A SPECIFICALLY OUR
ORGANIZATION IS MADE A STRATEGIC
PRIOR TO THIS YEAR --
AT FOUR AND FOR THE PAST TWO
YEARS TO FIND COLLABORATIVE
SOLUTIONS WITH OUR PLAY PARTNERS
TO FIND AT TO TRY TO MITIGATE
WILL SURELY BE --
A FINANCIAL CRISIS FOR FOR CITY
SPECIFICALLY I IN THE DECADES TO
COME --
OTHER ISSUES THAT THAT SORT OF
FALLEN IN MY WORLD IS.
SPECIFIC TO COLLECT A BARGAINING
AND NBA IN EMPLOYER EMPLOYEE
UNION ORIENTATIONS --
LEGISLATIONS RELATED LEGISLATION
THAT YOU'RE PER OF AND GUIDANCE --
AND POLICIES --
BIG ISSUES THAT WE'VE WORKED ON
TOGETHER --
DIVESTMENT ISSUES AND THINGS%
LIKE THAT FROM THE PERSPIRING
THE LEAGUE REMAINS VERY OPPOSED
TO THOSE SER DIE BESTEN MEASURES --
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE FUND IS
REALLY A CRITICAL SPOT --
IN SO YOU KNOW WAYS THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO BE A RESOURCE TO YOU --
YOU KNOW RELY ON US TO YOUR
CONDO BUT WITH OUR WITH OUR
REGIONAL REPRESENTATIVES ARE
PROFESSIONAL DEPARTMENTS ARE
DIVERSITY CAUCUSES ANYTHING THAT
YOU GUYS NEED AS FAR AS SPECIFIC
INFORMATION ABOUT HOW --
OPINION PIECE OF LEGISLATION IS
GOING TO IMPACT YOUR CITIES
OPERATIONS WERE HAPPY TO HELP
AND PROVIDE THAT EDUCATION --
THAT CONCLUDES MY TESTIMONY
THANK YOU.
THINGS WERE MUCH.
MORE PRESS HUESO OF CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS AT THANK
YOU FOR HAVING THE SCHOOLS VOICE
IN THIS CONVERSATION.
ON ACCESS A IS ONE IS A UNIQUE
ORGANIZATION COMPARED TO OTHER
ADMINISTRATOR ASSOCIATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY.
MOST OTHER STATES HAVE LIKE A
SUPERINTENDENT ASSOCIATION OR
PRINCIPLE ASSOCIATION ACTS THE
HOUSE ALL ADMINISTRATORS UNDER
ONE UMBRELLA SO WE ARE IN FACT
LARGER THAN OUR NATIONAL FEEL
YET BECAUSE WE CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE MORE MEMBERS --
AND SO WE AT BECAUSE OF THAT IT
PROVIDES US AND I THINK IN
AUTUMN A WONDERFUL OPPORTUNITY
TO BE ABLE TO HEAR ALL THE
VOICES IN ORDER FOR US --
TO INFLUENCE THE LEGISLATURE IN
BEATING --
WE HAVE TWENTY THREE WHAT WE
CALL JOB ALIKE COMMITTEES AND
COUNCILS DOUBLE LIKE SERVERS ARE
YOUR SUPERINTENDENTS YOUR
ELEMENTARY PRINCIPALS MIDDLE
SCHOOL PRINCIPALS HIGH SCHOOL
PRINCIPALS.
I WORK WITH OUR HUMAN RESOURCE
ADMINISTRATORS VERY CLOSELY --
AND SO WE HAVE TWENTY THREE
EIGHT OF THOSE WE REPRESENT BUT
CLASSIFIED AND CERTIFICATED --
ADMINISTRATORS AND THAT MEANS
ALL THE WAY FROM THE
SUPERINTENDENT'S ASSISTANT ALL
THE WAY UP TO THE SUPERINTENDENT
EVERYBODY IN BETWEEN.
WE'RE NOT A UNION WERE
MEMBERSHIP ORGANIZATION SO
PEOPLE CHOOSE TO BELONG TO
ACCESS SO WE EVERY YEAR WE GO
THROUGH THE MEMBERSHIP DRIVE IT
SUB CHALLENGING BUT WE WE HAVE
ABOUT EIGHTEEN THOUSAND MEMBERS
AT ABOUT THE TWENTY THREE OF
THOUSAND OR SO ADMINISTRATORS IN
THE STATE --
WE ALSO AND WE DIVIDE WE HAVE
FOR ADVOCATES AND WE DIVIDE THE
ISSUES MUCH LIKE THE LEAGUE DOES
BETWEEN ISSUE AREAS OF COURSE --
YOU KNOW WE DO A LOT IN
EDUCATION SPACE OUT BUT I HAVE
THE PRIVILEGE OF WORKING IN THE
LABOR SPACE AND SO --
IT'S NOT ALWAYS AN EASY --
YOU KNOW JOB TO HAVE BECAUSE
WE'RE IN THE POSITION OF HAVING
TO BALANCE WHAT WE WANT TO DO
FOR EMPLOYEES AND MAKING SURE
THAT OUR EMPLOYEES ARE TAKEN
CARE OF BUT ALSO ENSURING THAT
OUR STUDENTS ARE BEING SERVED SO
WE HAVE SORT OF I THINK.
A UNIQUE --
PUBLIC EMPLOYER EMPLOYER
PERSPECTIVE ALSO CONSIDERED AN
AGENT OF THE STATE OR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WERE SPECIAL DISTRICT
OR SCHOOL DISTRICTS SO WHENEVER
THERE'S LEGISLATION GOING
THROUGH WE'RE RIGHT WE'RE HAVING
TO KEEP A PRETTY VIGILANT ALLY.
ON THE IMPACT BECAUSE OFTENTIMES
WE FIND OURSELVES.
WITH UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
THAT WERE SUBSUMED INTO
LEGISLATION WHEN WE WEREN'T
SUPPOSED TO BE THERE. 8290% OF
OUR BUDGET GOES TO EMPLOYEES AND
SO THAT DOESN'T LEAVE A LOT FOR
ON THE OTHER ADDITION SAME PLACE
BUT FOR PEOPLE WHERE PEOPLE
HEAVY INDUSTRY AND WE HAVE
TEACHERS ADMINISTRATORS
CLASSIFIED --
AN OTHERS AND SO THAT'S WHERE
THE MAJORITY OF OUR OF OUR
BUDGET GOES --
WE ALSO LIKE THE LEAGUE HAVE --
HAVE ARE DIFFERENT CAUCUSES WE
ALSO ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE'VE TRIED TO IMPRESS UPON
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE AND
HIS STAFF THAT.
OUR MEMBERS ARE AT THEIR TO ADD
A COMPUTER SOMETIME DURING THE
DAY I MEAN MAYBE ELEVEN O'CLOCK
AT NIGHT BUT THEY'RE GOING TO BE
THERE.
SO WE HAVE AN ABILITY THAT IF
YOU HAVE EVER HAVE A QUESTION A
WHAT A POLICY POSITIONS GOING TO
BE WHAT IT COULD LOOK LIKE AND
WHAT MIGHT IMPACT BEYOND JUST
YOUR DISTRICT.
WE HAVE THAT A BILL AVAILABILITY
WE OFFER IT FREELY TO ANYBODY
WHO WANTS TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
IT THAT --
YOU'LL GET A GOOD PERSPECTIVE
IT'S NOT GONNA BE A 100% BUT YOU
CAN GET A GOOD FEELING OF WHAT
THE IMPACT WOULD BE THROUGHOUT
THE STATE.
WE HAVE NINETEEN REGIONS --
DIVIDED UP --
YOU KNOW STATE WIDE SO THOSE OF
YOU I'M SURE I'VE HEARD FROM
YOUR LOCAL --
SUPERINTENDENTS OUR PRINCIPLES
ARE OTHERS TING TO ISSUES THAT
ARE GOING ON IN THERE ON IN
THEIR DISTRICTS. ONE OF THE
OTHER THINGS THAT'S DIFFERENT
THAT'S CHALLENGING FOR I THINK
ON SCHOOL DISTRICTS AS A PUBLIC
EMPLOYER IS THAT WE ARE AND I
SAY THIS WITH ALL --
ADDED DECORUM I GUESS I WOULD
SAY THAT EVERY BUT I I'VE SAID
THIS FOR YEARS THAT I THINK
EVERYBODY THINKS ARE AN EXPERT
IN EDUCATION BECAUSE EVERYBODY
WENT TO SCHOOL --
OR YOU HAVE KIDS OR
GRANDCHILDREN WHO WENT TO SCHOOL
AND SO WE WE TEND TO DEAL WITH A
LOT OF ISSUES THAT.
I'M YOU KNOW REPRESENTING OUR
ADMINISTRATORS THAT MAYBE WE
THINK WE THINK THEY'RE A GOOD
IDEA BUT ARE THEY REALLY BASED
IN FACT AND AND POLICY THAT WILL
IMPLEMENT AND BE IT CAN BE
IMPLEMENTED IN THE LOCAL.
CONTACTS SO I WORK VERY CLOSELY
AGAIN AS I MENTIONED WITH OUR
OUR HUMAN RESOURCE
ADMINISTRATORS --
GUIDING ME AS WE MOVE THROUGH TO
TAKE POSITIONS ON LEGISLATION
ONE OF THE THINGS I DID WANT TO
BACK TRACK A LITTLE BIT ON AND
HOW WE TAKE POSITIONS ON
LEGISLATION.
WE HAVE OF LEGISLATIVE POLICY
COMMITTEE MADE UP OF PEOPLE FROM
EVERY ONE OF OUR JOB A LIKE.
A COMMITTEES AND COUNCILS AND
THEN REGIONAL REPRESENTATION SO
WHEN WE TAKE A POSITION WE HAVE
SOME EXPERTS IN THE ROOM TO A BE
ABLE TO HELP INFLUENCE WHAT
WE'RE DOING I THINK THAT IT DOES
SPACE OF OF HUMAN RESOURCES IS
SO LEGAL AND SO TECHNICAL THAT I
COULDN'T DO.
MY JOB WITHOUT THE HELP OF OUR
MEMBERS A BE ABLE TO GUIDE US AS
WE MOVED --
MOVE FORWARD SO --
AND THEY FINALLY JUST WANTED TO
LET YOU KNOW THAT I'M AS FAR AS
A LOT OF OUR PRIORITIES FOR THE
YEAR GOING FORWARD --
WE ARE -- IN
THE ISSUES OF THE OF THE COOPER
V. OF THIS COMMITTEE OBVIOUSLY
THE PERSON STARS PENSION
PRESSURES CONTINUE TO MOUNT FOR
US -- AND
WE'RE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT WHEN
WE LOOK AT IMPLICATIONS FOR
MAKING IS THE BILL ABILITY FARM
IN ARM AND EMPLOYEES TO BE ABLE.
TO DO THE REPRESENTATION WITH
THEIR UNIONS BUT THAT IMPACT IS
AT THE SCHOOL AND HOW WE HAVE TO
BALANCE THE THE FACT THAT ARE WE
NEED PEOPLE IN THE CLASSROOMS
AND OF THE SITE'S VERSUS BEING
ALSO.
MAKING SURE THAT OUR UNION
REPRESENTATIVES ARE ABLE TO DO
THEIR JOBS AS WELL SO IT'S
ALWAYS A KIND OF DELICATE
BALANCE THAT WE WE HAVE TO WALK.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE WITHOUT
ANY COMMENT SIR FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS [inaudible]
CENTER TAMPA.
HI SOON SO IF CAL HR HERO SAYS A
SIMILAR QUESTION ASKED THE
PERSONNEL BOARD TERMS OF AND
AGAIN I THINK THE PASSWORD KELLY
CHORES DONE.
WITH CIVIL RIGHTS BOARD BUT IN
TERMS OF TRYING TO INCREASE THE
DIVERSITY OF OUR LAST STATE
WORKFORCE.
SOME OF THE WORKS THAT --
YOU'D SEE DOING A DEGREE IN
EDUCATING PEOPLE ABOUT HOW THEY
CAN ENTER STATES SERVICE --
PEOPLE WHO ARE LIVING AND MORE
PERHAPS THIS EVENTUALLY
COMMITTEES MUSICAL WHICH MAY NOT
BE AS FAMILIAR WITH THE PROCESS
WHICH IS A BIT DIFFERENT THAN.
THE END.
LIMóN OUT IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR
AT TIMES RIGHT WHEN HE DID
THINGS THAT WE'RE CURRENTLY
DOING EXACTLY RE BRANDING HOW TO
GET A STATE JOB.
SO I KNOW YOU'RE FAMILIAR WITH
OUR STATE BY RECRUITER BRANDED
LETTER JOT HE'S WORKED WITH YOUR
OFFICE AS WELL AS ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS COOPERS.
AND HE IS.
ACTUALLY RE BRANDING AND WE'RE
LOOKING TO ROLL OUT --
GET THAT MESSAGE OUT WE ALSO
WILL BE OPENING UP CAL H. R. FOR
A COUPLE OF DAYS OF THE MONTH
INVITING THE PUBLIC IN.
SO WE CAN COMMUNICATE ON HOW TO
GET A STATE JOB --
AS SUSIE AND ROSE TO MENTION YOU
ARE MAKING BETTER TOOLS WE HAVE
THE CAL CAREERS TO ALLOW THEIR
DATES MAKE IT MORE EASIER FOR
PEOPLE TO NAVIGATE SO THAT
ACTUALLY IS GONNA.
HELP WE'VE GOTTEN A LOT OF
POSITIVE FEEDBACK FROM THE
PUBLIC --
ONE THAT TOOL AND SOLD BUT
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DOING
CURRENTLY [inaudible]
MMHM.
ANY OTHER IT THE QUESTION IF I
COULD WHICH CENTER GOING THANK
YOU VERY MUCH --
YOU KNOW DEAN THE UP HOWEVER THE
CITY'S WORKING AND I KNOW YOU
GAVE THAT GREAT EXAMPLE OF WHAT.
SAN MATEO COUNTY DID IN THE
THREE CITIES THAT ARE INVOLVED
IN THAT GPA.
BUT WHAT HOW ARE THE CITY'S
WORKING WITH THE PERS TAKE TO
KEEP BENEFIT COSTS.
YOU KNOW IN A COST TO THIS TO
THE CITIES IN THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS LOW I MEAN ARE
THEY WELL LOW AS WELL AS THE
LOWER ISN'T YEAH YEAH I I'VE MET
MANAGING I THINK WOULD BE THE
BETTER THE BETTER TERM --
YOU KNOW IT IT IT STARTS WITH
EDUCATION AND I'LL BE THE FIRST
TO TELL YOU THAT OVER THE PAST
TWENTY YEARS EMPLOYERS ARE
ABSENT FROM THE PER FOR THE
PURSE BOARD WE WE WE WEREN'T
THERE.
AND REALLY IN THE LAST THREE
YEARS QUITE APPARENT THAT --
AS EMPLOYER CONTRIBUTIONS
CONTINUE TO RISE --
IT'S SQUEEZING OUT ESSENTIAL
SERVICES AND SO WHEN YOU FOR
EXAMPLE WHEN YOU LOOK AT BE OFF
BY FISCAL YEAR TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIVE YOU'RE LOOKING AT
ABOUT 10% 212% OF CITY SPENDING
25% OR MORE OF THEIR ENTIRE
GENERAL FUND BUDGET.
SPECIFICALLY ON THE MINIMUM
PAYMENT ON THE PER SIDE ALONE
AND THAT DOES I MEAN THERE'S
THERE'S THE LOCALLY WE WORK WITH
ARE THE LABOR UNIONS TAT TAT TO
PAY SOME OF THAT PLAYER SHARE SO
I CERTAINLY WANT TO GIVE CREDIT%
WHERE CREDITS DUE --
BUT IT'S ABOUT EDUCATING THAT
THAT THE CALPERS BOARD AND
LETTING THEM KNOW THAT --
THE ACTIONS THAT THEY THAT THEY
TAKE --
CERTAINLY FALLS ON ON THE THE
THE BACK OF THE EMPLOYER IF THEY
FALL SHORT THEIR BASS RETURNS
AND THINGS LIKE THAT SO THE JOKE
AROUND CALPERS IS THAT IF I'M
YOU KNOW IF I'M NOT HERE WORKING
WITH YOU GUYS I'VE GOT A
BASICALLY AN OFFICE OVER THERE
SO IT'S IT'S IT'S CONCERT.
EDUCATION --
WORKING WITH THEM THERE'S BEEN
SOME AB TO WEAR PROVIDES NEW
OPPORTUNITIES FOR US TO ENGAGE --
BUT WE CERTAINLY --
ARE ACTIVE VOICES IS
PARTICULARLY IN THE LAST
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY FOUR MONTHS.
REALLY THANK YOU AND IN KNOWING
THE WORK THAT WE DO IN IN THE
LEGISLATURE IN IN THESE
COMMITTEES WHAT --
THE ISSUES THAT COME BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE IS WHAT WHAT DO YOU
THINK ARE THE MOST IMPORTANT
THINGS WE SHOULD BE LOOKING FOR
OR AT THIS YEAR WELL.
I THINK THAT YOU KNOW THEY'RE
THEY'RE ALREADY OF YOU KNOW AND
I I WON'T SPEAK OF SPECIFIC
MEASURES AT IT IN THIS FORUM BUT
I THINK ONE OF THE BIGGEST
ISSUES THAT.
WE FACE IS --
ON THE DIVESTMENT ISSUE --
I KNOW THAT THERE IS A ROBUST
CONVERSATION A COUPLE WEEKS AGO --
THE CITY FROM THE CITY'S
PERSPECTIVE --
IT IS SOMETHING THAT QUITE
FRANKLY YOU KNOW WHEN YOU PICK
WE KNOW WINNERS LOSERS WHAT WHAT
SOCIAL BECAUSE THERE IS TO TO TO
GET BEHIND --
IT'S A CHALLENGE --
BECAUSE REALLY DIVESTMENT
DOESN'T WORK AND RIGHT NOW WHEN
YOU HAVE A WHEN YOU HAVE A
CALPERS FIND THAT RIGHT NOW IS
ABOUT PROXIMALLY 6667% FUNDED
MEANING SIXTY SEVEN CENTS FOR
EVERY DOLLAR THAT'S TO THOSE
EMPLOYEES RETIREES THE TABLE AND
NOT NOT ALLOWING THOSE
INVESTMENT --
THAT DIDN'T DO VERY VERY CAPABLE
INVESTMENT TEAM TO MAXIMIZE
THOSE THOSE PROFITS. FOR FOR
THOSE PUBLIC EMPLOYEES THAT
REALLY IS COMPARABLE TO THE
BIGGER ISSUES THAT CAN BE COMING
UP THIS YEAR --
I THINK AS YOU SEE SOME OF THE
BILL THE LARGER COURT CASES
LOOMING --
WITH THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME
COURT --
THERE MAY BE A SOME SOME
MOTIVATION TO WORK
COLLABORATIVELY COLLABORATIVE
LEE TO ME TO CODIFY SOME OF
THOSE DECISIONS THAT NEED MAYBE
COMING OUT AND AND YOU KNOW
FIRST AND FOREMOST I THINK THE
LEAGUE.
WOULD VERY MUCH LIKE TO BE A
WILLING PARTNER --
IN WORKING WITH LABOR IN WORKING
WITH THIS COMMITTEE --
IT TO TRY TO FIND SOME SOME --
SOME COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTIONS TO
PERHAPS CODIFY SOME THIS COURT
CASES REVIEW THANK YOU IN THE
SAME QUESTION TO THE PANELISTS
IN TERMS OF WHAT ISSUES.
YOU THINK WE SHOULD BE LOOKING
AT HERE THAT WOULD GEN.
IN WHATEVER IMPORTANT.
IT'S A GREAT QUESTION.
BUT WE ALSO HAVE STIRS IN
ADDITION TO YOU KNOW PER SO --
AS FAR AS THE RETIREMENT ISSUES
GO WE'D GET IN JUST NEED HELP IN
BEING ABLE TO MEET OUR
OBLIGATIONS AS WHAT TING SAID IN
ONE OF THE OTHER THINGS WE TEND
TO SEE --
THERE TENDS TO BE LEGISLATION
THAT MOVES THROUGH THAT
PENALIZES THE EMPLOYER WHEN
THERE'S DIFFERENT EVENING BUT
WHATEVER ISSUE AND SO MAYBE
KEEPING IN MIND OF WHAT THAT
IMPACT WOULD BE ON THE EMPLOYER
BECAUSE IT'S NOT.
THE INDIVIDUAL THAT'S BEEN HEARD
IT'S THE SYSTEM ITSELF SO THAT
WE CAN AND I WOULD AGREE WITH
BOTH OF THESE PANELISTS THAT THE
WHAT IS THE ISSUE WE NEED TO BE.
THANK YOU APPRECIATE
[inaudible]
SENATOR PAT.
THANK YOU IDEA SHOULD OFF OFF
AND A COUPLE OF THE QUESTIONS
FROM CENTER HELLO --
SO FIRST OF ALL --
A. L. DIVESTMENT INITIATIVES
COME UP BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE
SINCE I PREVIOUSLY CHAIRED THE
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT THAT TIME
BETWEEN NOW THE TWO TOGETHER BUT
SO THAT THEY MIGHT HEARING THAT.
THE EMPLOYERS WILL BE PERHAPS --
STANDING UP AND TESTIFYING
MAURER AT REGARDING DIVESTMENT.
ABSOLUTELY I THINK I MEAN DID
THE LEAGUE OF CITIES --
AT LEAST AGAIN OVER THE PAST TWO
YEARS HAS BEEN VERY STRONG IDEA
ABOUT SOME MEASURES I'M AT BEST
MAN I THINK WHEN YOU GET TO THE
BUSINESS OF PICKING AND CHOOSING
YOU JUST HAVE TO HAVE A SOLID
LINE -- WITH
REGARD SAID TODAY BEST RIGHT NOW
THE FUNDS INTO CRITICAL THE
PLACE TO BE TAKING TOOLS OFF THE
TABLE.
OKAY -- AND
THEN I GUESS THE OTHER THING I
JUST WANNA MAKE NOTE AND I
APPRECIATE THAT --
WE'VE BEEN HEARING FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ABOUT --
PENSION PRESSURES --
BUT I WOULD ALSO MAKE NOTE THAT
FOR EXAMPLE DRAIN RECESSION AND
SOME OF THE CITIES THAT --
THE LOCALITIES I WORKED WITH YOU
KNOW THE WORKERS ACTUALLY AT THE
BARGAINING TABLE GAVE UP OUR
SAID THEY WEREN'T GOING TO TAKE --
SALARY INCREASES BUT AN ORDER
PROTECTOR PENSIONS.
AND SO --
BECAUSE OUR FUTURE PAYMENTS.
SOMETIMES IT'S EASY TO PICK ON
THEM AT BECAUSE YOU HAVEN'T HAD
THE CANDY CASH OUT YET --
BUT I I I I THINK WE JUST NEED
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT.
AND THAT PERHAPS YOU KNOW IF IF
THERE'S AN ISSUE ABOUT.
THEY ARE PENSION FUNDS NOT
PROVIDING ACTOR ENOUGH
INFORMATION. TO TWO TWO I GUESS.
THE LOCAL ENTITIES OR TO THE
UNIONS ABOUT WHAT THE COST MIGHT
BE IN THE FUTURE MAYBE WE SHOULD
FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO THAT BUT
ONCE YOU MADE AN AGREEMENT.
I THINK IT'S I I MEAN I THINK WE
HAVE YOU A CAUTIOUS ABOUT SAYING
THAT WELL NOW THAT WE'RE YOU
KNOW WE'RE FEELING PRESSURE FROM
AN AGREEMENT WE AGREE TO AND AND
NOW WE WATCH I ROLL SOMETHING
BACKS I KNOW THAT'S NOT WHAT
EXACTLY WHAT YOU'RE SAYING BUT
THAT.
SOMETIMES HEARD THAT USES AN
ARGUMENT TO SAY WHAT MADE IN THE
PAST YEAH I I CERTAINLY TEACHER
I CERTAINLY WILL --
AND WE DID NOT WANT TO COME OFF
AS A THAT WE WANT TO ROLL
ANYTHING BACK --
IN FACT IT WAIT WITH REGARDS TO
TO TO CONTRIBUTIONS I I'D GET A
DAY PRINT THE EMPLOYEES OF THE
AT THE TO NEGOTIATE TO PAY PART
OF THE EMPLOYER PLAYER THE OUT
PERSPECTIVE SO.
COMPLETELY GET UNDERSTAND YOU'RE
SAYING WHAT I ALSO THINK I WENT
OUT AND IT AND IT'S JUST THE
FACT OF THE OF THE TEACHERS ARE
MEMBERS BIG --
THEIR EMPLOYER BUT THEY'RE ALSO
AN EMPLOYEE SO THEY DON'T WANT
TO SEE THOSE BENEFITS ROLL BACK
EITHER I MEAN IT'S KIND OF JUST
THE NATURE OF THE BEAST AND SO I
DON'T KNOW IN THE SCHOOL SPACE
THAT WE SEE IN ANY OF THOSE ROLL
BACKS.
I HAVE NOT HEARD OF THAT AT ALL.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY HAD
QUESTION.
I APPRECIATE THIS CONVERSATION I
THINK WE ARE AT A VERY CRITICAL
TIME WITH THE SPECTER THE
PENSION SYSTEMS.
I THINK WE IN THE LEGISLATURE
NEED TO BE FOCUSING UPON REALLY.
WHAT'S GOING ON IS BROAD FIELD
AND HOW WE STE TACKLE IT
SYSTEMATICALLY.
I LOOK AT IT THROUGH THE LENS
YOU KNOW WE HAVE IN THE
GOVERNMENT CODE AT SECTION TEN
SIX HUNDRED AT SAC.
PROVISION FOR A JOINT COMMITTEE
RELATED PENSIONS.
IT'S EXISTING AUTHORITIES BEEN
THERE SINCE THE NINETEEN
EIGHTIES.
IT ACTUALLY.
CONCEDE OF A LIBERAL JOINT
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
AND IT.
AS CONCEPTUALIZE BACK IN THE
EIGHTIES IT ENVISIONED.
A WIDE ARRAY OF OUR STANDING
COMMITTEES EACH FINALLY IN A
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERT INTO THIS
JOINT COMMITTEE.
YET CONTEMPLATED A ADVISORY
PANEL OF THE TREASURE ANOTHER'S.
AN ADVISORY PANEL FINANCIAL
EXPERTS SO THE TOP.
A LAWYER WHO PRACTICES THE
PENSION FIELD A TOP INVESTMENT
ADVISER AN ACTUARIAL RESOURCE.
SORT OF TOP TIER PEOPLE IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR IN WITH EXPERTISE
INVESTMENT THIS WHOLE RAVE
ISSUES. TO THEM LET THE
LEGISLATURE.
START TO WRANGLE WITH THESE
ISSUES [inaudible]
ON TO ME HE I AM VERY CONCERNED
BECAUSE WHEN I LOOK AT OUR
ECONOMY. TWO THIRDS OF OF THE
GROSS DOMESTIC PRODUCT ARISES
FROM INDIVIDUAL CONSUMER
SPENDING.
SO WE ACTUALLY IF WE'RE GONNA.
LOOK AT HOW WE KEEP PEOPLE
WHO'VE BEEN IN THE WORKFORCE AND
THEN EXIT.
IN A POSITION SO THAT IN
RETIREMENT THEY CAN CONTINUE TO
SPEND.
AND SUPPORT OUR ECONOMY ACTUALLY
GOES VERY IMPORTANT.
THAT'S MUCH BIGGER THAN THE
BENEFACTION OF SOMEBODY.
HAVING TO ROUTE A PENSION.
BECAUSE IT IS A PUBLIC GOOD.
DOLLARS PEOPLE HAVEN'T JUST BEEN
RETIREMENT HELP US PULL THE
ECONOMY OUT WE HAVE SEEN SINCE
THE EIGHTIES A MOVEMENT TO FOR
ONE CASE.
WHICH TYPICALLY PEOPLE WE KNOW
AND THIS THE ELECTORAL COMINTERN
THIS GOING BACK THE NINETIES IS
PEOPLE DON'T KNOW HOW TO INVEST.
PEOPLE GET IN THEIR
ORGANIZATIONS PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
WITH FOUR ONE CASE THEY'RE DOING
FINE WHEN THE ECONOMY'S
ROCKETING ALONG.
WHEN THE ECONOMY TANKS THEY SEE
THEIR ASSET SHRANK?
THEY'RE SCARED TO DEATH TO
RETIRE.
BECAUSE THEY DO NOT HAVE ENSURE
SOURCES BEEN RETIREMENT.
WHICH MEANS A CLING TO THESE
JOBS.
BECAUSE THEY CLAIM THESE JOBS
ONLY WAY ORGANIZATION PROPER
PRIVATE CAN SKINNY DOWN.
IS A LOT OF BLOOD IN THE AISLES
ORGANIZATIONS SPEAKING.
THIS THE FIRST YEAR BUILD A
CLEAN OUT THE SENIOR RANKS OF
PEOPLE AND OPEN UP NEW JOBS FOR
OUR NEW COLLEGE GRADUATES.
AND I PERSONALLY THINK THAT THE
REASONS SOME IS MOST FOR MORE
RESOURCE SESSIONS HAVE BEEN SOLD
LINGERING.
IS BECAUSE OF THE COLLAPSE IN
SPENDABLE MONEY FOR PEOPLE IN
RETIREMENT. TO HELP US PULL
OURSELVES OUT.
SO I THINK THIS FUNDAMENTAL
ISSUE OF THE MODEL YEAR HER IN
WE DESCRIBE IS THE INTERNAL
COMBUSTION ENGINE DISFAVORED IN
THIS.
CLIMATE CHANGE YOUR FOR MANY
REASONS.
IS BUILT AROUND A FLY WHEEL.
AND THE WHOLE POINT OF THE FLY
WHEEL IS THE PISTONS BOUNCING
BACK AND FORTH IN THAT BLOCK.
WHICH TO CREATE A HECK OF LOT OF
VIBRATION IF YOU'RE IN THAT CAR.
THAT BY BRIDGE GETS MOVED OUT
BECAUSE IT GETS TRANSLATED TO
SMOOTHLY SPENDING.
FLY WHEEL INSIDE THE BLOCK THAT
SORT OF TAKES THE VIBRATION NOW.
AND I THINK WE NEED TO BE A
CERTI.
THAT THE FUNCTION.
OF PENSIONS.
IS TO SERVE AS A FLY WHEEL IN
THE NATIONAL ECONOMY. TO PROVIDE
A RESOURCE SO PEOPLE CAN.
EVEN IN A RECESSION DECIDE I'D
ACTUALLY LIKE TO HANG IT UP.
I'D LIKE TO HAVE MORE TIME MY
WIFE MY GRAND KIDS GO FISHING.
GO VISIT THOSE PLACES I'VE OFTEN
THOUGHT I WANT TO GO WHILE I
STILL HAVE MY HEALTH.
CREATOR MEANS FOR PEOPLE LEAVE
ORGANIZATIONS OPEN THEM UP FOR
THE NEW COLLEGE GRADUATES.
JUST SEEMS TO ME THAT IS A
CONSCIOUS TO HAPPEN I I ACTUALLY
THINK.
WE COULD DO LOOKING BACK TO THIS
MODEL IN THE GOVERNMENT CODE.
WE GET UNDER TAKE A MORE
SYSTEMATIC ROBUST THOROUGH
EXAMINATION AND THEN YOU START
TRYING TO DEAL WITH.
ALL -- PADS
AND OTHER SORTS OF THINGS BUT
YOU DO WITH AN INTELLECTUAL
FRAMEWORK WHERE YOU'RE SORT OF
UNDERSTAND OKAY IS NOT JUST A
BENEFACTION.
LUCKY THEY GOT THEIRS AND
SOMEONE ELSE GOT [inaudible]
MESSED UP.
AND PERSONALLY I ACTUALLY THINK
THAT THE WHOLE MOVEMENT TO FOR A
ONE CASE ARISES FROM THE AVON
LETTER WHICH WAS USE US
DEPARTMENT LABOR PAIN AND LETTER.
IN.
NINETEEN NINETY TWO THAT SAID
PRIVATE PENSION SYSTEMS HAD TO
VOTE THEIR SHARES IN ACCORDANCE
WITH.
THE BENEFICIARIES OF PRIVATE
PLAN SOMETHING GM CHRYSLER FORD.
THEY DIDN'T JUST WANT TO GO THE
ANNUAL MEETING VOTE THEIR SHARES
ON BEHALF OF MANAGEMENT.
BECAUSE THEY WERE THE GM FUND.
BUT THEY HAD OF VOTERS MOSES
SHARES BASED UPON THE WORKER
INTEREST.
AND THAT OPINION HIT AND YOU
STARTED SEEING THIS MOVEMENT TO
FOUR OH ONE K.'S WHICH IS
ACTUATED BREAK UP THAT. FOR YOU
SURE OBLIGATION AND BUILT DAHLE
THE SILOS SO I JUST THINK
SOMEBODY'S TO JUMP INTO THAT
CONVERSATION I THINK HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WE ARE IN A GOOD
POSITION TO DO THAT.
THESE SYSTEMS OPERATE OVER
THIRTY FOUR FRAME.
AND SO HISTORICALLY WE'VE SEEN
OUR PRINCES US IN A BAD PLACE
THEY DO ADJUST THE CERTAINTY
LEADERSHIP FROM.
FROM THESE TWO COMMITTEES IN THE
LEGISLATURE.
BUT I JUST FEEL LIKE.
WE START GETTING INTO --
PAD IN THE BURDEN ON CITIES ALL
THAT.
WE NEED SOME DETACHED REFLECTION
TO KIND OF REFLECT UPON WHERE IS
THIS ALL GOING.
WHAT'S THE ULTRA PUBLIC GOOD
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO SUPPORT
BECAUSE IT DEFINITELY IS HERE.
AND THEN START MAKING CHOICES IN
ACCORDANCE WITH THAT SO I I'M
SORRY FOR JUST JUMP.
BUT SOME REMEMBER O'DONNELL SAID
ABOUT THE FLY WHEEL YES.
EDU PRETTY BIG STUFF THERE
MISTER COOLEY --
BUT EITHER WAY JUST QUICKLY I
JUST WANTED.
MISTER HUTCHINGS ELITIST I'VE
GREAT COMMENTS ON DIVESTMENT
DOES NOT THE ROLE OF THE STATE
LEGISLATURE TO GUIDE THE
INVESTMENT STRATEGY.
ARE PENSION FUNDS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
AND WE NEED TO BE VERY RESISTANT
ON THAT OF LANGUAGE AND I'D LIKE
TO SEE THAT IN COMMITTEE WHEN
THOSE COME UP BECAUSE I'M SURE
IT'LL BE FIVE OR SIX THIS YEAR.
AND IT IS MY HOPE THAT THE
COMMITTEE WOULD REJECT THEM
BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT GOOD
STRATEGIES --
IN THE IMPACT THE OVERALL HEALTH
OF OUR PENSION SYSTEM FRAZIER --
IN THE THE IF WE'RE GONNA TALK
ABOUT --
SOME SOME SOME NECESSARY SOCIAL
ELEMENTS WE CAN TALK ABOUT THOSE
AT THAT AT THE PENSION BOARD
LEVEL.
THAT'S WHERE THAT CONVERSATION
BELONGS SO I APPRECIATE THAT.
AND JUST REGARD WITH REGARD TO
THE PENSION ISSUE OVER ALL I
THINK ANYTHING WE CAN DO AS A
STATE AND ACTUALLY LOCALS. TO TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS TO PAY DOWN
THAT DEBT AND A MORE AGGRESSIVE
FASHION --
WOULD BE WOULD BE IN A NET
POSITIVE FOR US LONG TERM WITH
THAT THANK YOU YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SEEN NONE THANKS VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR INPUT THANK YOU AND THANK
YOU AND MOVE ON WITH THAT SAID
WILL MOVE ON TO OUR LAST PANEL.
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES OR
REPRESENTATIVES ROLE.
WE'RE FROM THE STATE WE HAVE
MERRY HERNANDEZ EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR SEIU LOCAL.
ONE THOUSAND AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
WHERE OF CHRISTY BROWN MONTH
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS.
AND FROM THE SCHOOLS WE HAVE JAY
IT'S PORK ASK JOHN.
A I'M SORRY SUBDIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS.
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION AND THE SET BRAMBLE
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE WITH US
ONCE AGAIN YOU HAVE A TWENTY
MINUTES.
WHOEVER START --
I WAS JUST ADMIRING CHRISTIE'S.
TECHNOLOGY HERE I'M A LITTLE BIT
I GUESS FASHION.
HERE NOW I GOT THE GLASSES NOW
BUT DON'T HAVE THE I. PAD A WORK
ON THAT ALL I'M GONNA LET IT ON
KNOW ABOUT THAT --
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
ALLOWING LOCAL ONE THOUSAND TO
BE HERE TODAY --
TO PROVIDE OUR PERSPECTIVE ON
THIS IMPORTANT HEARING.
THANK YOU --
MR TEARS AND THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS --
FOR INVITING LOCAL.
ONE THOUSAND SO MY NAME IS MERRY
HERNANDEZ I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AT SEIU.
ONE THOUSAND AND WE REPRESENT
NINETY SIX THOUSAND STATE
EMPLOYEES AND NINE BARGAINING
UNITS ACROSS FOURTEEN HUNDRED
WORK SITE.
I THINK THE CAL HR DIRECTOR USED
A LARGER NUMBER SO WE CAN GO
WITH HER NUMBER IF --
IN A FOR THE PURPOSES OF THE
RECORD FORM MANY DIFFERENT KINDS
OF WORK INCLUDING TESTING
CRIMINAL EVIDENCE.
ISSUING DRIVERS LICENSES
PROVIDING HEALTHCARE TEACHING AT
THE SCHOOL FOR THE DEAF AND
BLIND JUST TO NAME.
A FEW A WE ARE THE LARGEST STATE
EMPLOYEE UNION IN CALIFORNIA
NATIONALLY WE ARE THE LARGEST
PUBLIC SECTOR UNION AND SEIU.
OUR MEMBERS EARN A MEDIAN WAGE
OF SIXTY THOUSAND DOLLARS IN OUR
PURCHASING POWER ADDS OVER EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS TO THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY.
WE REPRESENT A WORKFORCE THAT'S
COMPRISED OF 66% WOMEN. 34% MEN
AND THE END.
OF 62% PEOPLE OF COLOR.
AND WE ARE COMPRISED OF ROUGHLY
18% MILLENNIALS 52% CHEN AXE IN
31% BABY BOOMERS.
BUT LOOK WHAT LOCAL ONE THOUSAND
DOES GOES FAR BEYOND TRADITIONAL
LABOR ROLES --
WE BELIEVE UNIONS HAVE A DUTY TO
DO MORE. FOR THEIR MEMBERS THAN
JUST REPRESENT THEM IN CONTRACT
NEGOTIATIONS AND ENFORCEMENT.
WE ARE STRONG ADVOCATES I WAS
HAPPY TO HEAR THE CONVERSATION
AROUND PENSIONS BUT WE ARE
STRONG ADVOCATES FOR OUR MEMBERS
TO RETIRE SECURE RETIREMENT
SECURITY BUT WE ALSO WANT THE
CALIFORNIA WHERE EVERYONE.
CAN RETIRE WITH PEACE OF MIND.
AND WHILE I CAN RECITE A HANDFUL
OF STATISTICS ABOUT WHO OUR
MEMBERSHIP IS THE IMPORTANT
SERVICES WE PROVIDE AND HOW WE
REPRESENT THEM IN STATE CIVIL
SERVICE.
AT THE END OF THE DAY I DON'T
WANT YOU TO REMEMBER STATISTICS
I WANT YOU TO REMEMBER THE
PEOPLE OF LOCAL.
ONE THOUSAND WHAT AT WHAT A WHAT
A STRONG UNION CONTRACT I I
THINK I'M AN EXAMPLE OF WHAT A
STRONG UNION UNION CONTRACT DOES.
MY FATHER WAS A MEMBER OF CSEA
AND BECAUSE OF HIS CONTRACT I
WAS ABLE TO HAVE OPPORTUNITIES
AND TO BE HERE TODAY IN FRONT OF
SUCH A DISTINGUISHED BODY.
IT IN A IN A VERY PROFESSIONAL
ROLE -- BUT
LET ME TELL YOU A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT BRENDA FERGUSON.
SHE IS A TWENTY TWO YEAR.
EMPLOYEE AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
MOTOR VEHICLES SHE'S A MOTHER OF
THREE BOYS SHE'S BEEN BLESSED
WITH TWELVE GRAND BABIES.
OF WHICH THE OLDEST IS TWENTY
ONE THE YOUNGEST IS TWO AND IN
HER UNION SHE HAS GROWN INTO A
COMMUNITY FORCE.
HE HAS LED INCREDIBLE COMMUNITY
SERVICE PROGRAMS SUCH AS VITA --
CASH FOR COLLEGE --
TO ENSURE THAT WE DO EVERYTHING
WE CAN TO FIND THE MONEY TO MAKE
COLLEGE POSSIBLE FOR YOUNG
ASPIRING MINDS.
INTO ORGANIZES SACRAMENTO CREEK
WEEK SO THAT OUR MEMBERS HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE RIVER CLEANUP AND GIVE BACK.
SHE'S ALSO BEEN A FORCE IN
FIGHTING FOR FORMAL HOUSING
BECAUSE RENTS ARE OUT OF CONTROL
AND DOING NOTHING IS NOT AN
OPTION.
A ROSE --
DEL ROSA IS AN EMPLOYMENT
PROGRAM REPRESENTATIVE AT THE
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT IN WEST COVINA THAT'S
A MOUTHFUL.
OF SO SOME OF YOU MAY HAVE HEARD
ROSA STORY IN TWO THOUSAND AND
NINE YOU REMEMBER --
STATE WORKERS WERE FURLOUGHED
THREE DAYS A MONTH AND DURING
THE SAME TIME ROSE HIS BROTHER
WAS KILLED.
HE WAS A CONTRIBUTOR TO THE
HOUSEHOLD EXPENSES.
SUB ROSA ALSO CARED FOR FOR SO
ANYONE OF THESE CIRCUMSTANCES
WOULD BE TOUGH ALL ON ITS OWN TO
PUT THEM ALL TOGETHER AND THAT
WAS HER LIFE.
AND AS A RESULT OF THE FINANCIAL
HARDSHIPS SHE WAS TWO WEEKS LATE
IN HER MORTGAGE IN ONE OF THE
BANK DO THEY MOVE TO FORECLOSE
ON HER HOME.
SO SOMEBODY WHO WAS FURLOUGHED
LOST HER BROTHER WAS CARING FOR
HER DISABLED MOTHER WAS NOW
UNDER THE THREAT OF EVICTION AND
BECOMING HOMELESS.
BUT THAT'S WHEN HER UNION IN HER
COMMUNITIES STEPPED UP TO HELP
HER FIGHT AGAINST THE BANKS.
A YOUNG COMMUNITY ACTIVIST NAME
WENDY CARILLO WAS PART OF THAT
FIGHT IN TOGETHER UNION AND HER
COMMUNITY STOOD BY HER TO FIGHT
AGAINST THE BANKS.
INTO AN AND THEY ONE SO IT LOCAL
ONE THOUSAND WERE GUIDED BY OUR
PURPOSE STATEMENT THE PURPOSE OF
LOCAL ONE THOUSAND IS TO HAVE
THE POWER NECESSARY TO GIVE OUR
MEMBERS.
AND ALL CALIFORNIANS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE A GOOD LIFE
LIVE IN SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES
AND ENJOY THE FRUITS OF SOCIAL
ECONOMIC AND ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE.
SO YES IT'S ESSENTIAL TO HAVE A
STRONG CONTRACT THAT PROVIDES
FOR GOOD WAGES GOODBENEFITS A
STRONG STRONG WORKPLACE
PROTECTIONS FOR OUR WORK DOESN'T
STOP THERE.
WE HAVE A DUTY TO ENSURE THAT
ALL OF OUR CHILDREN'S EDUCATION
IS SOLID WE HAVE A DUTY TO
ENSURE THE ENVIRONMENT IS
PROTECTED. FOR ALL GENERATIONS
AND WE HAVE A DUTY TO ENSURE
THAT YOU CAN WALK FREELY ON THIS
EARTH AND THAT YOU ARE NOT
TARGETED BECAUSE OF THE COLOR
YOUR SKIN.
OF THE COUNTRY OF ORIGIN OR WHO
YOU LOVE.
SO IF YOU REMEMBER ANYTHING
ABOUT WHO LOCAL ONE THOUSAND IS
AND WHAT OUR ROLE IS I REMEMBER
ROSE GET DOWN REMEMBER BRENDA
FERGUSON.
AND REMEMBER THAT OUR MEMBERS
ARE MORE THAN JUST A TO SIX FOR
LEADERS AND WE ARE CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU CHRISTY FOR GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEES.
OF MY NAME'S KRISTY BOMB I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
FOR THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
APPEAR BEFORE YOU THIS MORNING
AND SPEAK ON BEHALF OF HALF OVER.
THIRTY THOUSAND MEMBERS OF
CALIFORNIA'S PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS.
WE'RE THIRTY THOUSAND COMMITTED
COURAGEOUS MAN WOMAN WOMEN
WORKING IN YOUR COMMUNITIES.
ANSWERING THE CALL EVERYDAY TO
EVERY TYPE OF EMERGENCY FROM THE
TAP CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRE TO THE
LIFESAVING MEDICAL CALLS THAT
CAN HAPPEN AROUND THE CORNER.
A CPF IS IN ESSENCE A UNION OF
UNIONS THE NEARLY A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY LOCALS REPRESENTED BY CPF
IN CALIFORNIA.
UP REPRESENT THOSE THIRTY
THOUSAND LOCAL STATE AND FEDERAL
FIREFIGHTERS WITH IN CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE CONSIDERED THE STATE
COUNCIL OF THE INTERNATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF FIRE FIGHTERS AND
ALL OF ITS AFFILIATES ARE AYE A.
F. F. LOCALS.
BUT LIKE ANY PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT
ORGANIZATION OUR MISSION IS TO
WORK TO IMPROVE THE LIVES WHAT
HAPPENED WON'T SCROLL.
OF WE WORK DIVERSITY.
TO IMPROVEMENTS IN THE LIVES OF
OUR MEMBERS --
LIVELIHOODS AND IN THE CASE IN
THIS CASE FRONTLINE FIREFIGHTERS
FOR MORE THAN EIGHT DECADES CPF
HAS WORKED ON BEHALF OF PAID AND
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND ACROSS STATE
AGENCIES.
WE ARE NOT LIKE LOCAL ONE
THOUSAND THE BARGAINING AGENT
FOR FIREFIGHTERS IN CALIFORNIA
THAT'S THE JOB OF OUR LOCAL
UNIONS.
RATHER WE PURSUE LAWS AND
POLICIES.
WORKING WITH ALL OF YOU.
OTHER ALLOW LOCAL AFFILIATES TO
EFFECTIVELY BARGAIN AT THE
WORKPLACE FOR PAY AND BENEFITS
AND WORKING CONDITIONS AND
RETIREMENT SECURITY FOR MEMBERS.
IN FIGHTING ON BEHALF OF OUR
MEMBERS WERE ALSO WORKING TO
SECURE AND PROMOTE THE SAFETY OF
ALL CALIFORNIANS WE FIGHT HERE.
TO ENSURE THAT OUR FIRE SERVICES
A PROPERLY STAFFED EQUIPPED AND
TRAINED TO MEET THE SAFETY NEEDS
OF OUR STATE.
THE OUR WORK IN SACRAMENTO OVER
THE YEARS IMPROVED PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
REQUIREMENTS THE CHILLED
FIREFIGHTERS FROM THE EXTREME
CONDITIONS THAT ARE PART OF
THEIR JOB EVERY DAY.
OUR WORK CAN BE SEEN IN THE
WORKERS COMPENSATION PROTECTIONS
THAT WE ASK YOU TO SUPPORT FOR
JOB BECAUSE ILLNESSES AND
INJURIES.
OF PROTECTIONS THAT RECOGNIZE
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY RISKS THAT
ARE PART OF THIS JOB.
OF WHEN OUR WORK CAN BE SEEN IN
WORKING FOR SECURE RETIREMENT
FOR OUR FIREFIGHTERS THAT EARNED
AND WHERE THE WEAR AND TEAR AND
THE HUMAN TOLL.
OF THIS OF DIFFICULT JOB.
BUT IT CAN BE SEEN IN
PROTECTIONS AGAINST RETALIATION
DISCRIMINATION BAD FAITH
BARGAINING INCLUDING OUR BASIC
FIREFIGHTER BILL RATES SO THEY
CAN PERCEIVE DUE PROCESS.
A IN THE PROTECTION OF THEIR JOB.
IN WI FI FOR LOCALS IN THIS
CAPITOL FOR LOCALS CAN DO RIGHT
BY THE MEN AND WOMEN WHO PUT ON
THE UNIFORM EVERYDAY.
AND PROTECT THE STATE.
IN SACRAMENTO THE DECISIONS THAT
YOU MAKE DIRECTLY IMPACT THE
LIVES IN THE FUTURES OF THESE
DEDICATED PUBLIC SERVANTS.
FIREFIGHTERS AND EVERY LOCAL
PUBLIC EMPLOYEE THAT I'M SITTING
HERE TO REPRESENT TODAY.
LIKE ALL PUBLIC WORKERS
FIREFIGHTERS DESERVE A VOICE IN
THE HALLS OF POWER.
AND AS A UNION ORGANIZATION WE
HOPE TO GIVE THEM THAT VOICE.
OF THE CAUSE IS NOBLE NECESSARY.
A U. S. FIRST DID SPEAK ABOUT
SOME OF OUR PRIORITIES IN THE
COMING SESSION.
OF THAT AFFECT THE LIVES AND
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
FIREFIGHTERS.
BUT ONE THAT IS A BECOME OF
GREAT PROMINENCE SO RECOGNITION
AND ALSO RECOGNITION BY THE
COMMUNITY IS UNBEARABLE MENTAL
AND EMOTIONAL TOLL OF THE JOB WE
DO.
A TO MEET THIS CHALLENGE WE'RE
LOOKING TO AUTHORIZE APPEAR
SUPPORT PROGRAM THAT INCLUDES
STATE STANDARDS AND
CONFIDENTIALITY SO WE CAN WORK
TO HEAL OUR OWN.
UGH BUT THIS EXTREME MENTAL TOLL
ALSO ACCUMULATES OVER TIME.
LEADING TO POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS
AND SOMETIMES TRAGICALLY SUICIDE.
TO MEET THIS CHALLENGE CPF IS
SEEKING TO HAVE A POSTTRAUMATIC
STRESS PRESUMPTION.
A TO BE DODD WITH IT WITHIN THE
WORKERS COMPENSATION SYSTEM TO
PROVIDE TREATMENT ONCE SOUGHT
OUT BY FIREFIGHTERS SO THEY CAN
GET BACK TO WORK.
OF OUR FIVE FIREFIGHTERS ON THE
FRONT LINES OF EMS DELIVERY AND
BASIC HEALTH CARE --
AND THIS THREAT POSED BY
OVERCROWDING EMERGENCY ROOMS TO
OUR COMMUNITIES WERE PROPOSING
TO IMPROVE EMS DELIVERY IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND WE UNABASHEDLY SUPPORT FIRE
BASED EMS AND COMMUNITY
PARAMEDIC SERVICES.
BECAUSE SOMETIMES RETIRED
FIREFIGHTERS BEEN FORCED TO PAY
THE PRICE FOR THE BUREAUCRATIC
MISTAKES IN THEIR RETIREMENTS
CPF IS PROPOSING AGAIN THIS YEAR.
UP TO PROTECT RETIREES FROM FOR
THE CLAWBACK OF RETIREMENT BEST
BENEFITS THAT WERE PROMISED.
AND PAID.
FOR AND I AM PROUD.
SO VERY PROUD TO BE PART OF CPF
IN ITS MISSION FOR NEARLY TWENTY
YEARS YOU WILL SEE ME IN THIS
COMMITTEE MOST OFTEN AND
SOMETIMES MY TEAMMATES.
OF MEGAN OR DOUG SUBER'S.
OF THERE'S NO HIGHER CALLING THE
WORKING TO PROTECT THOSE WHO
PROTECT ALL OF US.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY.
THANK YOU AND JACQUELINE LAST
ONE THAT ONE OF THE NIELSEN.
ARMED GOOD MORNING AND CHAIRMAN
RODRIGUEZ AND CHAPARRAL --
MY NAME IS CHAI SO PROCESS --
THE ASSISTANT DIRECTOR FOR
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS.
AT CSEA --
CSEA REPRESENT --
ESSENTIALLY TWO AND FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND CLASSIFIED SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES.
THESE ALL THE SUPPORT I'VE SAID
THIS BODY IN.
PREVIOUS ROLES I STARTED MY
CAREER WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AND THEN CAME
HERE TO JOIN THE ASSEMBLY
EDUCATION COMMITTEE WITH DAN
DELAYING EASTON.
WHO BECAME A STATE
SUPERINTENDENT AND I WAS BROUGHT
BACK INTO THE BUILDING WITH THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE TO OVERSEE QUE TO
UNIVERSITY LEGISLATION UNDER TO
SPEAKERSHIP?
SO I'M WELL AWARE AND WILK
FAMILIAR WITH THE KIND OF ALL
THE ISSUES --
ON EDUCATION AND AND HAVE BEEN
WITH CSEA NOW FOR A NEARLY
TWENTY YEARS AND HAVE BEEN
WORKING TO COMBINE THE TWO
ROUNDS OF LABOR AND EDUCATION.
AT THE END OF THE DAY I'LL
MEMBERS OF THE FIRST PEOPLE TO
STUDENTS WILL SEE A MEMBERS PICK
UP THREE TWO AM. TO GET THE BUS
STARTED TO BRING THE KIDS TO
SCHOOL --
THEY HELP FEED THE KIDS SO THAT
THEY ARE READY TO LEARN --
THEY ARE THERE TO HELP US SOME
OF ADMINISTRATIVE AND OUT
TEACHERS STAFF TO ENSURE THAT
KIDS HAVE ALL THE SERVICES THEY
NEED TO HAVE TO HAVE A SAFE
CLEAN LEARNING ENVIRONMENT.
DOES THAT THE MEMBERS THAT WE
TALK ABOUT WHEN I TALK ABOUT HOW
ISSUES YOU'LL SEE WHAT THEY CARE
ABOUT THE MOST THAT IS THE
WELFARE OF THE CHILDREN. TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE THE BEST
EDUCATION SYSTEM POSSIBLE IN
THIS COUNTRY --
THAT'S LITERALLY DER DER GOLDEN
LIFE AND YOU SEE THAT IN OUR
MISSION --
AS I MENTIONED WE HAVE ABOUT TWO
AND FORTY FIVE DOLLARS --
SECRETARY DOES A TEACHER FOOD
SERVICE WORKERS SAFETY OFFICERS
TECHNOLOGY EXPERTS CUSTODIANS
AND OTHER ESSENTIAL EMPLOYEES
WHO HELPED TO RUN OUT SCHOOL.
WITHOUT US LITERALLY TO SCHOOLS
WILL OPEN --
AND YOU KNOW WE WILL ASK A
COUPLE QUESTION WHAT'S THE
IMPORTANCE OF PHAM REPRESENT
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES IN.
IN IN IN IN DISPATCH THEIR BODY
AND WHAT ARE THE INTERESTS OF
OUT OF ORGANIZATION FOR THIS
YEAR LEGISLATIVE SESSION.
I WOULD SAY THAT YOU KNOW IF YOU
HAVE NOT GONE TO A WEBSITE YET
PLEASE DO --
WE STARTED IN. NINETEEN TWENTY
SEVEN ONE OF THE OLDEST UNIONS
AROUND.
GOING ON ALMOST A HUNDRED YEARS
NOW AND WE STARTED BECAUSE TEN
PEOPLE TEND CUSTODIAN NOTICE.
THAT A LADY WAS NOT GONNA BE
ABLE TO RETIRE WITH ANY TIME SO
WE WERE FUNDAMENTAL AND CIVIL
FOUNDING MEMBERS WERE ACTUALLY.
WALKING THE HALLS OF THIS
BUILDING TO WORK WITH --
OF GOVERNOR BLIND AND OTHERS TO
HELP ESTABLISH WHAT'S NOW TO BE
KNOWN AS THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT SYSTEM.
VERY PEOPLE PEOPLE KNOW THAT AND
I WEBSITE WILL SHARE AGAIN WOULD
HAVE SOME HISTORICAL DOCUMENTS
WHICH A LOT OF THE STAFF IN THE
BUILDING AND MEMBERS WHO GO BACK
AND MEMBER.
CLOUT THAT DOES NOT A FOUNDING
DOCUMENTS TO HELP CREATE THIS
SYSTEM THAT WE NOW HAVE --
AND THAT WAS BACK IN NINETEEN
TWENTY SEVEN TODAY WE CONTINUE
TO FIGHT FOR BETTER PAY AND
WORKING CONDITIONS FOR MEMBERS.
AND IN RECENT YEARS YOU KNOW AS
YOU -- MY
BOSS WHO'S RETIRING WITH THE
DAVE LOCAL --
YOU KNOW WE'VE BEEN ADDED AND
WE'VE BEEN SUCCESSFUL ON TWO KEY
AREA WHICH IS ON PENSION FIGHT.
AND IN EUROPE STOPPING ON THE
EFFORT TO PRIVATIZE OUR MEMBERS
JOBS.
THERE'S A VALUE TO SOMEONE WHO
HAS EXPERIENCE IF YOU TRIED TO
BRING IN SOMEBODY WITH NO
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT THE NEEDS
OF THE CHILDREN ARE.
ALL THE ROUTES OF THE BUSES TO
HOW THE CATHETER SHOULD BE
REPLACED TO HOW TO PROTECT THE
KIDS WHEN THEY'RE NOT IN THE
CLASSROOM.
DOES THAT THE EXPERIENCE YOU
WANT AND WHEN YOU CONTRACT OUT.
YOU LOSE ALL THAT YOU GO TO THE
LOWEST BID.
AND INSTEAD OF HAVING THAT LONG
TERM EXPERIENCE THE DEDICATION
ON CAMPUS YOU LOSE ON ALL THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS SO THOSE ARE THE
ESSENTIAL FIGHT THAT WE HAVE.
AND THAT'S JUST TO QUICKLY GO
OVER SOME OF OUR PRIORITIES HERE.
UNITE YOU KNOW WE'VE HAD LONG
TERM RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND WORKING ON SO
MANY DIFFERENT ISSUES --
I WOULD JUST MENTION THAT YOU
KNOW THE ONE OF THE FIRST ISSUE
THAT WE'RE WORKING WITH A NUMBER
OF OTHER KEY UNIONS S. YET YOU
SEE T. A..
R. THE FIREFIGHTERS AND OTHERS
THE PUBLIC UNIONS OF ONE
THOUSAND ALSO A IS TO ENSURE
THAT RELEASE TIME FOR ALL
MEMBERS TO DO THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING BUT IT'S WELL --
ACCOMMODATED OF WELL LISTED
BONTA TO TRY TO MAKE IT CLEAR
THAT.
THESE EMPLOYEES SHOULD HAVE THE
RIGHT AND THE TIME TO AT LEAST
GO MEET WITH EMPLOYERS.
AND ONE OF THE NEW THINGS THAT
HAS BEEN IN PLACE --
BY GOVERNOR BROWN WHICH IS TO
ALLOW US TO BE ABLE TO TALK TO
NEW EMPLOYEES AT THE ON A PLAY
ORIENTATION --
WE WOULD LIKE TO MAKE SURE THAT
AND THOSE KINDS OF ACTIVITIES
THAT INCLUDE SO THAT'S ONE OF
OUR FIRST PRIORITIES.
AND THIS BILL --
YET ISSUES YOU'LL SEE BECAUSE WE
BRIDGE THE WILL OF LABOR AND
EDUCATION CHARTER SCHOOL I KNOW
ASSEMBLYMAN.
O'DONNELL IS OUT IN A SPARE
HEADING OF A BIG EFFORT TO KIND
OF MAKE MAKE IT MAKE SENSE.
RIGHT THEY WERE INTENDED AND I
WAS HERE WHEN THEY WERE CREATED
THAT WERE INTENDED TO BE ONE
HUNDRED INNOVATIVE SCHOOLS.
BUT WE HAVE NOT HEARD VERY MUCH
ABOUT WHAT SOME OF THOSE
INNOVATIONS ARE.
YES THERE ARE SUCCESS WHOSE
CHARTER SCHOOL IN SOME PLACES IN
OUR STATE BUT WHEN THEY'VE GROWN
FROM A HUNDRED TO THIRTEEN
HUNDRED WE'RE SEEING A LOT MORE
OF THE ABUSES.
AND THE PLENTY OF STUDIES THAT
WILL POINT OUT WHAT HAPPENED
WHEN YOU START CONTRACTING OUT
WHAT HAPPENED WHEN YOU HAVE SELF
DEALING THAT'S WHAT ALL DOES
COUNT CONFLICT OF INTEREST
ISSUES.
COME BACK INTO PLAY WITH THAT
ISSUE IS A AND THE GOVERNOR AND
TO TRY TO PROVIDE MORE
ACCOUNTABILITY.
TO THAT PROCESS --
IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET I THINK WE
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT PENSION
POSE AND STOWS.
WOULD REALLY --
YOU KNOW EXCITED TO HEAR THAT
THE GOVERNOR.
SEES IN THE IMPORTANCE OF
PENSION AND WHAT THAT'S A WAY TO
RECRUIT PEOPLE AS TO BE TO
INSURE THAT WE HAVE THE BEST
WORKERS POSSIBLE.
BUT WE ARE UNDER FUNDED --
RIGHT NOW WE DO SOME AND HAVE
UNFUNDED LIABILITY BUT AT SOME
OF THE MEMBERS HAVE ALREADY
TALKED ABOUT IT CAME FROM A
CRASH IN THE MARKET.
ALL TRYING TO RECOVER HERE THERE
WAS A TIME WHEN IT WOULD ZERO
EMPLOYEE CONTRIBUTIONS.
BETWEEN EIGHTY TWO TO EIGHTY
EIGHT PM.
IN THE EIGHTIES IT ACTUALLY WENT
DOWN.
2% FOR THE IMPLANT THAT SUIT
QUITE BUT EMPLOYEES AND NOBODY
REMEMBERS THAT ANYMORE --
AND WE ALL THE PANIC AT THIS
STAGE WHEN WE ARE TRYING TO
BUILD IT BACK UP AS HAD BEEN
MENTIONED EMPLOYEES CONTRIBUTE
TO THE SYSTEM.
IT'S A GREAT SYSTEM THAT ENSURE
THAT [inaudible]
IT'S ABOUT TWO THOUSAND A MONTH
THAT'S A LOT TO LIVE ON AND I
HAVE A FATHER WHO YOU KNOW.
AT TRIED TO COBBLE ALL THAT
TOGETHER IN THE CITY OF SAN
FISCAL THAT JUST WAS REALLY HARD
TO DO --
FINALLY --
AS A TALK ABOUT WHAT DO I
MEMBERS CARE ABOUT THESE ARE THE
KINDS OF ISSUES THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO COVER THIS YEAR.
STATE SCHOOL SAFETY.
I'LL CONVENTION HAPPENS EVERY
SUMMER AND FOR THE LAST SEVERAL
WEEKS CONVENTION WHAT DO THEY
FIGHT WHAT THEY SAID LET'S MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYBODY'S TRYING. TO
KNOW WHAT TO DO WHEN THERE'S A
CRISIS ON THE SCHOOL SITE.
AND SO THIS YEAR WE'RE LOOKING
TO WORK TO ENSURE THAT EVEN PARK
TIMELY.
GET THE BASIC TRAINING AND WE
ALSO WORKING WITH OTHERS TO
ENSURE THAT.
EVEN WHEN A SCHOOL POLICE
OFFICER IS INJURED ON THE JOB.
TO GET THE BASIC WORKERS COMP
COVERAGE THAT GIVES THEM A FULL
YEAR'S PAY ESSENTIALLY THAT'S
ALREADY AFFORDED TO CITY
OFFICERS FIREFIGHTERS.
YOU KNOW EVEN LIFEGUARDS AND AND
YOU KNOW IT UP AFFORDED IN THE
LA UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT WHICH
I THINK ANY OFFICES.
IN ANY SCHOOLS IN A CUT SCHOOLS
AND COLLEGES IS ONLY ABOUT NOT A
FIFTY SITE SHOULD HELP THOSE
KINDS OF COVERAGE ALSO SO THAT'S
THAT'S KIND OF THE WHAT'S GOING
ON YOU KNOW HE'S PUTTING
TOGETHER THREE BILLION DOLLARS
FOR TEACHERS TO TRY TO HELP WITH
THE EMPLOYER COSTS.
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL I THINK YOU
KNOW HIS TEAM MAY HAVE NOT DONE
DOT THROUGH ABOUT HOW THE FACT
THAT FULL CLASSIFY STAFF --
WE WORK IN A SCHOOL THAT WE'RE
ON THE EARLY SO THAT THE SCHOOL
POOL IMPOSE.
AND WE ARE TRYING TO BRING IT TO
HIS ATTENTION THAT.
IT ONLY COSTS ABOUT A HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO
HELP DO THE SAME THING TO REDUCE
THE COST WITH EMPLOYERS --
IN OUR SCHOOLS SO THOSE ARE OUR
PRIORITY THEM HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTION YOU MAY HAVE THANK
YOU.
GO HEAD NECK.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MY NAME
IS SET BROWN BILL I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION.
CTA EXISTS TO ADVANCE THE CAUSE
OF A FREE UNIVERSAL IN QUALITY
PUBLIC EDUCATION.
WE WERE FOUNDED IN.
EIGHTEEN SIXTY THREE CITY HAS
BEEN WORKING TO IMPROVE THE
CONDITIONS OF TEACHING AND
LEARNING NOW FOR MORE THAN A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY YEARS.
WE ACHIEVED OUR FIRST
LEGISLATIVE VICTORY IN EIGHTEEN
SIXTY SIX WITH THE ESTABLISHMENT
OF FREE PUBLIC SCHOOLS FOR ALL
CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA.
IN NINETEEN TWENTY SEVEN SEAT TO
A ONE A MAJOR LEGAL VICTORY WHEN
THE SUPREME COURT RULED THAT THE
SCHOOL BOARD CANNOT FIRE A
FEMALE TEACHER SIMPLY BECAUSE
SHE GOT MARRIED.
IN THE YEAR OF MY BIRTH NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE CTA LED THE FIGHT
TO ESTABLISH COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING IN CALIFORNIA FOR
PUBLIC SCHOOL EMPLOYEES.
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
EXISTS TO PROTECT AND PROMOTE
THE WELL BEING OF ITS MEMBERS WE
NOW REPRESENT MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
EDUCATORS IN CALIFORNIA ARE
MEMBERS ARE CLASSROOM TEACHERS
THEIR SCHOOL COUNSELORS THEIR
SCHOOL LIBRARIANS.
SOCIAL WORKERS SCHOOL
PSYCHOLOGIST SCHOOL NURSES.
THESE EDUCATORS IN THE K. TWELVE
SCHOOL SYSTEM I JOIN BY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FACULTY
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
FACULTY.
AND EDUCATION SUPPORT
PROFESSIONALS TO MAKE C. T. A
THE MOST INCLUSIVE AND POWERFUL
VOICE OF EDUCATORS IN THE STATE
AS EDUCATORS WE ARE DEEPLY
COMMITTED TO THE SUCCESS OF
EVERY STUDENT I KNOW THAT.
MY BROTHER JOHN I WAS TALKING
SOME ABOUT HIS BACKGROUND SO
I'LL GIVE YOU SOME OF MINE JUST
TO ILLUMINATE THE STRUCTURE OF
C. T. I WAS A CLASSROOM TEACHER
IN SAN JOSE --
I WAS ON THE BARGAINING TEAM FO
THE MOUNT PLEASANT EDUCATION
ASSOCIATION IN SAN JOSE.
I WAS AN ELECTED PRESIDENT OF MY
LOCAL CHAPTERS SO WE HAVE A
SYSTEM OF LOCAL CHAPTERS ALL
OVER THE STATE.
OF CTA LOCALS --
AND YOU KNOW WE'RE CERTAINLY
NEGOTIATING ENFORCING CONTRACTS
WHICH ARE APPROVED BY THE
MEMBERSHIP IN EACH ONE OF THOSE.
LOCAL ASSOCIATIONS --
C. T. EIGHT DOES SUPPORT THOSE
LOCALS IN COMMUNICATIONS AND
BUDGET ANALYSIS ALL KINDS OF
OTHER SUPPORT WE PROVIDE --
THE JOB I HAD MOST RECENT TO
BEING HERE WAS AS THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE SACRAMENTO SEATS
CITY TEACHERS ASSOCIATION.
I THINK THAT WAS MORE THAN A
DECADE AGO BUT BUT DIDN'T DO
AGAIN STAFF WORK FOR THE
ORGANIZATION CONNECTING ALL THE
RESOURCES OF CTA TO THAT LOCAL
CHAPTERS SACRAMENTO CITY
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION.
HOW DO WE TAKE POSITIONS ON
LEGISLATION WE HAVE?
A GROUP THAT'S KIND OF SEPARATE
FROM HOW ARE LOCAL CHAPTERS ARE
ELECTED THAT ELECTS FOLKS
STATEWIDE TO SOMETHING CALLED
SEA TO A STATE COUNCIL AND SO
SEVEN HUNDRED EIGHT HUNDRED
MEMBERS COME TOGETHER AND HAVE A
MEETING LITERALLY NOT JUST THE
RIGHT POLICY AND GIVE ME MY
MARCHING ORDERS.
BUT ALSO TO TAKE POSITIONS ON
LEGISLATION VERY FUN TO WATCH
EIGHT HUNDRED PEOPLE HAVE A
MEETING TO DEBATE A PIECE OF
LEGISLATION --
BUT WE ARE FIERCELY DEMOCRATIC.
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION EGGS DIGNITY AND
CIVIL RIGHTS OF ALL CHILDREN AND
YOUTH ARE PROTECTED
ORGANIZATIONALLY WE ARE
IMPLEMENTING A STUDENT CENTERED
PROACTIVE AGENDA FOR PUBLIC
EDUCATION.
BY USING THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA TO PROMOTE THE
LEARNING ENVIRONMENT.
WE IDENTIFY NETWORKS OF
EDUCATORS TO DEVELOP
PROFESSIONAL AND CULTURAL
CAPITAL TO STRENGTH IN TEACHING
AND LEARNING WE ARE AN AFFILIATE
OF THE NATIONAL EDUCATION
ASSOCIATION.
AND PRODUCT DURING CALIFORNIA'S
LABOR MOVEMENT --
WE PARTICIPATE IN SOCIAL JUSTICE
CAMPAIGNS THAT IMPACT THE LIVES
OF OUR EDUCATORS STUDENTS.
AND OUR COMMUNITIES.
YOU WILL NO DOUBT SEE PROPOSALS
A SESSION THAT CAN MAKE THE
TEACHING PROFESSION MORE OR LESS
ATTRACTIVE TWO COLLEGE STUDENTS
SEEKING EMPLOYMENT OPTIONS.
SO I WOULD ASK YOU TO CONSIDER
WHEN YOU SEE THESE PROPOSALS
WHETHER YOUR CHILDREN WOULD BE
MORE LIKELY TO CHOOSE TEACHING
AS A PROFESSION BASED ON THAT
PROPOSAL.
A CT MEMBERS REPRESENT A FULL
SPECTRUM OF PROFESSIONS WITHIN
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS AND COLLEGES
AND TAKE ENORMOUS PRIDE.
IN THEIR WORK AND WE ASK YOU TO
RECOGNIZE EDUCATION
PROFESSIONALS FOR THE EXPERTS
THAT THEY ARE.
AS TRUSTED PROFESSIONALS
EDUCATORS ARE BEST EQUIPPED TO
MAKE SCHOOL AND CLASSROOM
DECISIONS TO ENSURE STUDENT
SUCCESS FINALLY.
THE ATTACKS COMING ON THE LABOR
MOVEMENT THREATEN CALIFORNIA
VALUES I AS I MENTIONED I WAS A
CLASSROOM TEACHER AND THE UNION
PRESIDENT I'M A BELIEVER IN
COLLECTIVE ACTION I'M A BELIEVER
IN COLLECTIVE VOICE.
I'M A BELIEVER IN WORKERS COMING
TOGETHER IN A UNION ESPECIALLY
IN THE ENVIRONMENT OF PUBLIC
EDUCATION WHERE BILLIONAIRES WHO
HAVE NEVER TAUGHT IN THE
CLASSROOM IN SOME CASES NEVER
SET FOOT IN A PUBLIC SCHOOL.
BELIEVE THEY KNOW BETTER.
OF THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION EXISTS TO SECURE A
MORE JUST EQUITABLE AND
DEMOCRATIC SOCIETY I REALLY
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
AND FOR YOUR TIME.
AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT THE COMMITTEE HAD
IT'S AT THIS OR ANY COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE I WANT TO THANK.
YOU FOLKS FOR COMING. FOR TO
MAKE YOUR PRESENTATION THANK YOU
FOR ALL THE HARD WORK YOU DO IN
YOUR REPRESENT.
WITHOUT BEFORE WE AND WE HAVE --
PUBLIC COMMENT I DON'T KNOW IF
THERE'S ANYBODY.
IN THE AUDIENCE ARE WILLING TO
PARTICIPATE IN PUBLIC COMMENT.
LAST SEEN IN HEARING NONE.
UNDER HIM ANY CLOSING REMARKS TO
CHEER YOU RUN ONE HECK OF A AT
EFFICIENT COMMITTEE THANK YOU.
WITHOUT ON THAT THANK OF MY CO
CHAIR MEMBERS PALACE.
AND THE PUBLIC FOR PERSISTENT
INVADE AFFORD IT TEARING MORE
DETAILS FROM STAKEHOLDERS IN THE
FUTURE.
UNLESS THERE ANY OTHER COMMENTS
FROM MEMBERS.
THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED THANK
YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE THIS
AFTER A MORNING [inaudible]
A JERK